ARE TRANSPORTATION PER DAY.
THERE ARE. THE LEGISLATURE LOSS
WHEN THEY'RE OWNS- CATULUS IGN
LAST WEEK AND THERE'S A FUNERAL
THAT'S HAPPENING SOLD A COUPLE
OF OUR MEMBERS ARE AWAY AND
GIVEN THE- HEALTH CARE CONCERNS
AND OTHER MEMBERS AWAY SO WE
WILL PROCEED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
THIS MORNING- ON ALL MATTERS
I'VE ALSO MADE THE DECISION
THAT WE WILL HOLD OPEN ALL OUR-
MATTERS BEFORE US. AND AT THIS
TIME. MOVING OVERTURE FOLLOWING
HEARING SO THOSE WHO WERE ON.
THE ADMINISTRATION RESPECTING
QUICK APPROVAL ON SOME OF THE
MATTERS WHICH IS AS A COURTESY
TO EVERYBODY GIVEN THIS UNUSUAL
SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN THIS
MORNING THE WHOLE THING'S OPEN.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO MOVE TO
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR- WE'RE
NOT TAKING ANY ACTION TODAY BUT
IF THERE'S MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT ARE HERE I LIKE TO
OPEN THE PUBLIC. HEARING ON
THAT. OKAY THURSDAY WAS CLOSE
THE PUBLIC HEARING WE WILL
CONTINUE- THAT THE MATTERS FOR.
VOTE ONLY AT A LATER DATE SO
LET'S MOVE TO A DISCUSSION I
ITEMS AND LET'S BRING UP-
CALTRANS FOR THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER ELEVEN LA LA. WE'LL HEAR
ABOUT OUR LOCAL AIRPORT LOAN
ACCOUNT IN THE- THEY'RE NOT X.
ACCOUNT GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU
UGH GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
THANKS FOR HAVING THE
DEPARTMENT HERE THIS MORNING
CALTRANS IN- MEMBER STERN
THANKS FOR GIVING US THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT. A FEW
ITEMS ON ARE A FEW ITEMS ON OUR
BUDGET. ALL START WITH THE
AIRPORT IMPROVEMENT GRANT-
MATCHING FUNDS THE PARCHMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION REQUEST A TEN
MILLION DOLLAR IN A FUND
TRANSFER. OF TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY OVER
FOUR YEARS FOR THE LOCAL
AIRPORT LOAN ACCOUNT TO THE
AERONAUTICS AGO. THE TRANSFER
WILL PROVIDE AN INCREASED
ANNUAL LOCAL ASSISTANCE FUNDING
CAPACITY OF TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND THE
AIRPORT. IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
MATCHING GRANT PROGRAM. THE TO.
ON THE AIRPORT. HELLO GIVE ANY
COMMENTS ON A THE UNDER UTILIZE
FUN. HI IAN THIS ROW WITH THE
LA L. SO WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
REGARDING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ALLOWING TO SEE TFA TO
COLLECT THE FUEL TAX- DATA
BECAUSE THIS WILL ULTIMATELY
HELP THE STATE GATHER
INFORMATION TO COMPLY WITH THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS- AS FOR
THE REQUEST TO TRANSFER FUNDS-
FROM TE LOAN ACCOUNT TO THE
AERONAUTICS ACCOUNT WE FOUND
THE PROPOSED TO BE REASONABLE.
AND THERE SEEMS TO BE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE AMOUNT THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN TRANSFER
FROM THE LOAN ACCOUNT TO THE
AERONAUTICS ACCOUNT IF THE TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION IS
INSUFFICIENT IF THE DEMAND- IS
GREATER THAN THAT- HOWEVER THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO- MY
VISIT IN FUTURE. IF THAT
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND CAP FOR
THE GROUP- THE GRANT IS. YEAH
EVERYBODY HERE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WILL BE HEARD AND SUB
FOR FIRST STEP TO BUT IT'S GOOD
TO HAVE THE INFORMATION WHAT I
DO. I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
FEDERAL MATCH IS ON THE- NAM X.
ACCOUNT MISTER DIRECTOR IN WHAT
THAT POTENTIAL IS FOR. THESE
AIRPORTS TO ACTUALLY UTILIZE
THE FUNDS TO DO THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE THINK
SHOULD BE DONE. YEAH I WAS
GERMAN I DON'T HAVE THE
DETAILS- ON ON THE FAA GRANTS.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE MATCHING
REQUIREMENT IS THE- FEDERAL
GRANTS TYPICALLY REQUIRE AN
EIGHTY TWENTY EIGHTY- EIGHTY
TWENTY- MATCH. AND FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE NOT BEEN.
MEETING SOME OF THOSE- SOME OF
THOSE MATCH REQUIREMENTS WERE
LEAVING SOME FEDERAL MONEY- ON
THE TABLE AND SALAS ON THIS-
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL GIVE US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
MATCH THOSE. TO MATCH THOSE
GRANTS- AS NEEDED THE PROJECTS
TYPICALLY RANGE IN A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR RANGE
OF THE GROUP THE GRANTS. THAT
WE DO SO THIS WILL THIS WILL
ALLOW US TO BE ABLE TO- TO
PROVIDE THOSE BILLS MATCHING
FUNDS AS NEEDED FOR THOSE
GROUNDS ANYTHING ELSE AT
FINANCE. SURE JAMES WHERE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO- THE
WAY THAT THE- AIRPORT
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM WORKS AT
THE FAA LEVEL IS THAT THE-
ENTITIES THE LOCAL AIRPORTS
APPLY DIRECTLY NOT THROUGH THE
STATE TO THE FAA. THE FAA
PROVIDES 90% OF THE PRODUCT
AMOUNT AND THE STATE HAS TO THE
LOCAL ENTITY COMES UP WITH TEN
PERCENT. THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
MADE A COMMITMENT TO HELP WITH
THAT 10% MATCH BY FUNDING 5%
AND THEN THE LOCAL AIRPORT HAS
COME UP WITH THE OTHER FIVE
PERCENT. ON THEPROPOSAL THAT
WE HAVE- IN IN FRONT OF YOU IS
TO. THE SUIT CONTINUE THE A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
MATCH WHICH ALLOWS NINETY PLUS
PERCENT OF THE PROJECTS TO GET
THE FULL 5% FROM THE STATE-
THIS TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD HELP. MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THAT 5% UP
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND- AS
ELLIE- NOTED THERE IS EXISTING
STATUTORY AUTHORITY THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO TRANSFER MORE MONEY
FROM THE LAW ALLOWED TO THE AND
OTHERS ACCOUNT. IF THAT TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WAS
INSUFFICIENT- IT'S BEEN OUR
PRACTICE THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
TO TRANSFER USING EXECUTIVE
ORDERS. ENOUGH TO FIND THAT 5%
UP TO WHATEVER THE CAP IS AND
WE WOULD CONTINUE TO DO THAT IF
THE TWO POINT FIVE- IS
INSUFFICIENT. AND PRESUMABLY IN
THE AIRPORT WORLD THEY WOULD
KNOW THAT WE'VE MADE A FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT SO THAT THEY'RE
PLANNING WOULD BEREFLECTIVE OF
THAT IN GOING OUT AND SEEKING
THE FEDERAL SYSTEMS. THAT'S
GREAT YOU'RE THINKING THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE
DIDN'T JUST CONTINUE WITH AD
HOC EXECUTIVE ORDERS EACH YEAR
WE WANTED TO LAY OUT- SOME
STABILITY TO SIGNAL TO THE-
INDUSTRY THAT THERE WAS. A
COMMITMENT ONGOING. CENTER
STERN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
QUICK CLARIFYING QUESTION-
JUSTIN ARE THERE PENDING
APPLICATIONS ARE FOR THE
DIRECTOR OR FOR DEAL WEAPON ARE
THERE PENDING APPLICATIONS FOR
MANY CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS
TOWARDS THE FEDERAL PROGRAM
RIGHT NOW THAT YOU GUYS ARE
SORT OF LOOKING AHEAD AT DO YOU
ANTICIPATE. ANY SPECIFIC TYPES
OF PROJECTS COMING OVER THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS I KNOW I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH LA ACTS AS A
MAJOR OVERHAUL GOING ON AS A
PH<c.cyan>ND I'M JUST TRYING TO</c>
RIGHTS AS MY OWN EXPECTATIONS
FOR WHAT WHAT WHAT COULD WE SEE
COMING OUT OF THIS AERONAUTICS
ON IN ORDER TO QUALIFY IT LEAST
IN ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR THE
STATE'S MATCHING- A PART OF THE
AP GRANT. THE IT HAS TO BE THE
PROJECT HAS TO BE PART OF THE-
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PLAN TO
SIMPLY A TEN YEAR IMPROVEMENT
PLAN THERE'S CURRENTLY ABOUT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
PROJECTS ON THAT PLAN AND-
SINCE. THE AIRPORTS THE QUALIFY
FOR THE STATE'S MATCHING PART
THE GENERAL AVIATION AND THE
RELIEVER AIRPORTS THERE'S ABOUT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
PROJECTS UNDER THOSE UNDER THAT
SUB CATEGORY OF THOSE SO- SO
THERE'S A LOT OF PROJECTS THAT
ARE THAT ARE ON THEM PER PLAN
THAN THAT ARE ESSENTIALLY
AVAILABLE FOR WHATEVER FUNDING
IS MADE AVAILABLE BY THE FEDS.
AND THE DEFENSE ARE REALLY THE
TRIGGER HERE WE JUST FOLLOW ON
SO WE'RE SORT OF WAITING ON THE
F. A. DEPENDING ON HOW THEY
WANT TO CORRECT THE ANNUALLY
THERE'S A THERE'S A NATIONAL
BUDGET OF THREE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS AND- THAT'S
MADE AVAILABLE FOR THE PROGRAM
AND THERE'S- MOST A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF THE GRANTS OURS
ESSENTIALLY ALLOCATED TO THE
STATE'S INTO THE AIRPORTS IN
THE STATE'S BASED ON- TRAFFIC
THE AFTER AVERAGE DAILY
PASSENGER VOLUME AND YOU KNOW
IT'S A LOT OF METRICS. THAT
THAT THEY PUT ALL TOGETHER AND
THEY COME UP WITH A NUMBER IN
THE STATE GENERALLY. YOUNG
STATE CALIFORNIA GENERALLY GETS.
TWO HUNDRED AND- TO TWO HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION A PER YEAR BASED
ON FAT FORMULA. AND THEN IF
THERE'S ADDITIONAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE OUT OF THE THREE
POINT ONE BILLION OR- OR THAT
THE OTHER THREE WOMEN OR IF
THERE'S ADDITIONAL-
APPROPRIATIONS MADE THAN THOSE
THAT MONEY GOES INTO-
DISCRETIONARY FUND AND THAT'S
BASED ON WHAT'S- YOU GIVE IN.
DIDN'T WE LIKE SO WE HAVE OUR%
LIST OF WE HAVE OUR CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT PLAN LIST OF
PROJECTS AND ALL OF THOSE CAN
BE. PART OF. THE LAST QUESTION
JUST I KNOW I'VE HEARD A
DISTINCT. CONCERN RELEASE FROM
A FEW MAJOR AIRPORTS ABOUT
THEIR FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE NEED. UNDER THE NEW LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD FRAMEWORK
WHERE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
PRODUCING AND UTILIZING LIKE
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS TO NEWER
NOBLE JET FUEL AS WELL AS WELL
AS RENEWABLE THESE ON SITE AND
ALSO CHARGING. INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THEY'VE THEY'VE INQUIRED
ABOUT HOW TO. SORT OF FINANCE
THAT AND I DIDN'T KNOW IS THAT
KIND OF CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
SHOULD THEY WANT TO PUT IT INTO
THIS FRAMEWORK IS THAT KIND OF
THING ELIGIBLE LIKE A FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENT A
STORAGE CAPACITY ON SITE. THE
BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE THOSE TO
BE ELIGIBLE PROJECTS AND
THERE'S A THERE'S A LONG LIST
OF VERY INTRICATE THINGS BUT I
MEAN I DON'T KNOW OF ANY REASON
WHY THOSE TYPE PROJECT. THANK
YOU. ONE THING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO POINT OUT SENATOR
CENTERS THAT AS FAR AS OUR
MATCHING. PROGRAM GOES FROM THE
STATE- BECAUSE ITS MAIN FOCUS
IS TO HELP MOSTLY SMALLER
AIRPORTS. PERFORM TRANSPONDER
PROJECTS WITH A MINIMAL
INVESTMENT PLACES LIKE LA ACTS
AND AS OF ANOTHER COMMERCIAL
AIRPORTS ARE NOT RECEIVING A
MATCHING FUNDS FROM THE STATE
THIS IS REALLY DESIGNED ABOUT
THE SMALLER RURAL GENERAL
AVIATION AND SOME RELIEVER
AIRPORTS VERY GOOD THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION ARTLESS
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS
IS ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN AIRPORT
IMPROVEMENT GRANT MATCHING.
FUND WE'LL CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
AND WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS
MATTER OPEN- LET'S MOVE TO THE
LITTERBOX EVIDENTLY HAVE A VERY.
IT'S A GROWING LETTER BACK
PROBLEM THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT ON ABATEMENT. PLEASE
PROCEED DIRECTOR YES THE GERMAN
THANK YOU- UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
AND SO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION IS REQUEST IN AN
INCREASE OF. THIRTY ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
INCREASING TO A PERMANENT
INCREASE OF FORTY THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TO TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. FOR THE DIVISION OF
MAINTENANCE TO FUND THE LATER
ABATEMENT PROGRAM. HIGHWAY
LITTERING ILLEGAL DUMPING IS
GROWING SUS IS A GROWN SOCIETAL
CONCERN. THAT PLAGUES THE
TRAVELING PUBLIC AND THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA. THE
LETTER ABATEMENT PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TO REMOVE LETTER
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. EXISTING
LEVEL OF RESOURCES CANNOT
ADDRESS THE INCREASED VOLUME OF
HIGHLY LETTER ANY ILLEGAL
DUMPING. AND CAN'T MAKE CLEANUP
SERVICES OR SPECIALIZED
SERVICES FROM WATER CLEAN UP
CONCERNS ARE NOT INCLUDED IN
THIS REQUEST. THE REQUEST
PROVIDES A PERMANENT INCREASE
IN DEDICATED RESOURCES TO
IMPROVE LATER BUT MAN ON THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM. THANK
CHAIRMAN. THAT INTERACT WITH
THOSE ALTHOUGH SIGNS WE SAY
THIS STRUCTURE HIGHWAYS BEING
SERVICED BY ABC CORPORATION
WHAT'S THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN
THOSE PEOPLE AND THIS 40%
INCREASE THAT YOU HAVE ON
SERVICE REQUEST I SUMA SERVICE
REQUEST IS SOMEBODY SOME GOOD
NEIGHBOR CALLS UP AND SAYS HEY
THERE'S A MATTRESS ON- STATE
ROUTE ONE SIXTEEN OF OR
WHATEVER IT IS AND- THOSE HAVE.
INCREASE DO YOU GUYS CALL HEY.
ABC CORPORATION GO GET THAT
MATTRESS IT'S THIS IS YOUR PART
OF THE HIGHWAY OR DO YOU GUYS
GO OUT. ALTHOUGH AS IT WERE
THAT THAT'S A THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION I MEAN THAT'S A
COMPLETELY SEPARATE- PROGRAMME
GERMAN- THE ADOPT A HIGHWAY
PROGRAM IS ROUGHLY. WERE SICK
WERE REDUCING THE NUMBERS WRONG
FOR ROUGHLY FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IS HOW MUCH THAT'S
COSTING US TO DO THAT PROGRAM.
THAT'S A COMPLETELY SEPARATE
FROM THE COSTS THAT WERE SEEN-
WITHIN THE MAINTENANCE DIVISION
ON ON LETTER PICK UP AND
CABINET RELATED ISSUES RIGHT
NOW ROUGHLY A HUNDRED A HUNDRED
AND TWO MILLION DOLLARS JUST
AND DOING CLEAN UPS AND-
WORKING ON IN COMMENTS IN CLEAN
UP LITTER SO WE'VE GOT. THAT A
MIX CHALLENGE IN FRONT OF US AS
RELATES TO THIS OUR OUR
MAINTENANCE FORCES ARE
INCREASINGLY HAVING TO ADDRESS
ISSUES RELATED TO- BUT THE
HOUSING ON AND SHELTERED BUT
THE VOLUNTEER EFFORTS THAT
YOU'RE YOU YOU MENTION ARE
DEFINITELY HELP US I MEAN IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE COMPANIES-
VOLUNTEER OUR TIME- ANYA FORCES
TO HELP US OUT WITH THIS WITH
THESE EFFORTS BUT TWO SEPARATE
PROGRAMS. IF YOU WILL. SAME
LATER SO THE SO THE ADOPT A
HIGHWAY PROGRAM HAS SOME SORT
OF FIXED FREQUENCY THE PEOPLE
GO OUT THAT THE YOU KNOW IT IN
ORDER TO GE YOUR NAME ON THE
HIGHWAY THAT YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE
GOOD CITIZEN YOU GOT TO IT ONCE
A YEAR TWICE A YEAR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT AND WE STILL HAVE
SEEN. IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS AS
77% INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT OF
LITTER ON THE ON THE ROADS
RIGHT SO THE CONSUMER IS MORE
OF A LITTER BUG THE ADOPTED AND
WE ALWAYS THOUGHT I ALWAYS
THOUGHT THAT THESE ADOPTED
LATER ADOPTED FREEWAY PROGRAM
STARTED JUST TOOK CARE OF ALL
YOUR WORK JUSTIN MAGICALLY
DISAPPEARED. IN LA- YOU HAVE
ANY OF LITTER. A PERSPECTIVES
TODAY RECOMMEND IS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE PROPOSAL TO
AUGMENT FUNDING FOR CALTRAIN
DOES LITTER ABATEMENT SERVICES-
THERE ARE ASSESSMENT WE FIND
THE DATA DEBT DEMONSTRATES THAT
THE VOLUME OF TRASH ON THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM HAS RISEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IN AND AS A
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL- WORKLOAD
FOR CALTRANS. WE FIND THAT
THESE CONDITIONS ARE LIKELY TO
PERSIST WHICH WARRANT THE
AUGMENTATION. HOWEVER WE ALSO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTS SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE REQUIRING CALTRANS TO
PROVIDE AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
GROWING LITTER ISSUE- IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. IT SEEMED AS THOUGH
THEY DON'T HAVE A CLEAR
INDICATION ON WHAT THE DRIVERS
WERE. AND WE BELIEVE HAVING
SUCH INFORMATION COULD ASSIST
THE STATE AND FINING EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES TO PREVENT LITTER IN
THE LONG RUN. AS YOU MAY KNOW
WHAT THE DRIVERS ARE HE JUST
DON'T KNOW TO THE DEGREE IS IT
IS IT ILLEGAL DUMPING IS IT
JUST PEOPLE THROWING OUT THERE
THERE. DRINKS OUT THE WINDOW OR
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN WE WOULD
PROBABLY KNOW THE COLUMNS ARE
THAT THERE THAT HEY THE I.
OPPORTUNITIES- THAT PEOPLE HAVE.
ANYTHING TO ADD. I THINK THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH- YOUR STAFF
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU NEED.
SERVICE RUNNING WHAT THE CAUSES
ARE OF THERE THERE IS SOME
EXISTING REPORTS A CALTRANS AS
PUT OUT THAT TOUCHES ON SOME OF
THESE ISSUES AND SO WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO DIRECT YOU TO THEM TO
SATISFY WHATEVER- NEED YOU HAVE
AS FAR AS LEARNING ABOUT. THE
RESOURCES BUT WE CAN WORK WITH
YOU TO PROVIDE THE- CENTER
STERN. THANKS MISTER CHAIR AND-
I REALLY APPRECIATE. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL HERE AND
THE PRODUCTIVITY ON YOUR PART.
PILING UP FOR A LONG TIME THIS
ISSUE AND- IT IT DESERVES LEVEL
SERIOUSNESS SITE I WOULD CONCUR
WITH THE LAOWES ANALYSIS FOR
APPROVAL I DID WANT TO ASK THE
JUST FROM THE INITIAL DATA YOU
HAVE- HOT SPOTS THAT YOU'RE
SEEING I MEAN DO YOU DO AS HAVE
SORT OF BEEN GEOGRAPHIC
INTENSITY AREAS- AT THIS POINT
LOOK WHAT IS THE MAP LOOK LIKE
STATEWIDE. WELL EXCUSE ME IF
THE THAT THE GREAT QUESTIONS TO
STERN OF GILBERT THAT RESPONSE
THE DIVISIONAL BUT JUST ACTING
CHIEF- RIGHT NOW TO OUR
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM. THE WAY WE
IDENTIFY THE NEEDS BASS ON
LEVEL OF SERVICE AND WE
IDENTIFY ALL THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE REQUEST THAT WE RECEIVE
STATEWIDE- DETERMINE THE
PRIORITY AS FAR AS WHERE THE
LITTER IS. AND WHAT TYPE OF
PRIVATIZATION IS GOING TO BE
GIVEN TO THOSE AREAS TO BE
PICKED UP. THE LETTER IS
STATEWIDE THE MORE URBAN AREAS
THE DUKE CONGREGATE LIVING MORE
LITTER PC. BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE LIVING IN THOSE
SITUATIONS WE'RE SEEING A LOT A
LITTLE WITHIN THE RURAL AREAS
AS WELL. WE ARE TRYING TO
IDENTIFY SPECIFICALLY TO BE TO
THE LA THOSE CONCERNS AS FOR
THE TYPE LEADERS GOING THERE
HOW IT'S GETTING THERE. AND THE
TYPE OF POCKETS ARE GONNA BE
TAKING TO REMOVE THAT LATER-
BUT PRIMARILY. WE PRIORITIZE
THE WORKLOAD BASED ON THE
CUSTOMER SERVICE REQUEST THAT
WE DO RECEIVE A STATEWIDE AND
THEN FROM THERE WE IDENTIFY
THAT THAT WORKS. NO THE
MAINTENANCE CREW THAT WOULD BE
USED AS A REQUEST DRIVEN I MEAN
DOES IT COME TOP DOWN FROM YOUR
ANALYSIS AND THAT SORT OF
COMBINES WITH REQUESTS FROM THE
GROUND OR IS IT COMING MOSTLY
YOU EVALUATE. LIKE THE SQUEAKY
IS WE'LL IS GOING TO GET THE
ATTENTION BECAUSE IT'S SORT OF.
IT'S REALLY BASED ON. REGIONAL
REQUEST. YEAH IT IS A
COMBINATION OF BOTH- BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LEVEL SCORE STATEWIDE
FOR EACH OF OUR DISTRICTS. AND
WHEN THOSE REQUESTS COMMAND WE
IDENTIFIED THE NEED BASED ON
THE LITTLE CREW THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE IN THOSE AREAS AND THE
COMBINATION THAT INFORMATION.
DRIVES IT AND IS THERE ANYTHING
WE CAN DO I KNOW. YOU SAID-
DIRECTOR THIS IS SEPARATE FROM
IN CANTON ISSUES OR THIS IS
GOING TO. THIS ACTUALLY ALLOWS
FOR SOARED ANCILLARY CLEAN UP
AROUND. IT DOES IT DOES SO I
KNOW THERE'S COMPLEXITY TO THAT
WORK AND A LOT OF IT FALLS ON
YOUR FOLKS. TO NAVIGATE THE
LEGAL COMPLEXITIES- EVERYONE
LOVES DLE CALTRANS ABOUT WHAT
THINGS LOOK LIKE UNDER THE
FREEWAY BUT NO ONE REALLY HAS
THE SAME TOOLS THAT YOU DO TO
ACTUALLY GO TACKLE IT IS THERE
ANYTHING WE CAN BE DOING TO-
HELP YOU GUYS NAVIGATE THAT IS
IT. DO YOU NEED MRE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS LIKE WHAT WHAT.
WHAT'S WHAT ARE MISSING PIECES
HERE THAT WE CAN NAVIGATE SOME
OF THE- LEGAL COMPLEXITIES
AROUND THIS AND ALLOW YOU TO
ACTUALLY. GET THE MONEY OUT THE
DOOR BUT DOING IT OUT IN IT IN
A WAY THAT'S HUMANE AND
RECOGNIZING SOME OF THE CRISES
WE HAVE I MEAN DO YOU DO. ARE
YOU MISSING TOOLS RIGHT NOW OR-
YOU KNOW. THE ALL HANDS ON DECK
APPROACH THAT WE ARE WE'RE ALL
USING THE- THE LEGISLATURE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND ALL THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S- I THINK IS THE
APPROACH WE SHOULD BE. USING
THE MORTAR THINGS WERE FOCUSED
ON NOW IS GETTING MORE CITIES
ACROSS THE STATE TO SIGN A
LEASE AGREEMENT- WHAT WERE WERE
POSSIBLE SO WE HAVE READY TO
USE LEASE AGREEMENTS FOR
CALTRANS IT'S- A PROPERTY
COUNTY. RIGHT AWAY. SO FAR
WE'VE ONLY GOT FIVE CITIES ON
BOARD- THAT. IN WOULD RECALL
SORRY TO INTERRUPT YOU BUT
WITH. ONE OR TWO CITIES- SURE-
SAN JOSE SACRAMENTO- OAKLAND-
SERVICES GOING AND A
LIABILITIES OKAY YEAH OF THE
ONLY CITIES THAT WE HAVE A- ON
A LEASE AGREEMENT WHAT TO USE-
CALTRANS- RIGHT AWAY AND
CALTRANS PARK PROPERTY. SO
ENCOURAGING CITIES ACROSS THE
STATE- MEMBERS OF CITIES THAT
ARE IN YOUR IN YOUR DISTRICTS.
WHERE THEY HAVE ISSUES. LAW TO
WORK WITH US OWN AGREEMENT IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD WE WOULD
STRONGLY LIKE YOUR HAVE YOUR
HELP AND YOUR ASSISTANCE AND
ENCOURAGEMENT. AND THIS IS THIS
FOR COUNTIES TO WRITE A JOB SON
INCORPORATED AREAS YOU NEED
COUNTY BUYING BUT LA COUNTY SO
FAR IS NOT OPTED INTO ANY SUCH
LEASE AGREEMENT DON'T BELIEVE
SO. I DON'T BELIEVE SO. AND IN
THIS IN SEVEN CALIFORNIA SOUNDS
LIKE ONLY CITY OF LOS ANGELES
RIGHT NOW YES I THINK SO VERY
GOOD THANKS TO GWEN AND ON A
WRITER. THANK I HAVE THIS
THURSDAY IF I CAN JUST CLARIFY
TO PLEASE THIS PCP DOES NOT
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING
CABINETS OR WATER CLEAN UP
SERVICES IS SHORTLY JUST FROM
THE CRICKETS FOR LATER BUT- BUT
I GUESS. READING INTO IT THERE
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO. BE
SORT OF ANCILLARY OR SORT OF.
LEADER TO NOW. DIRECTED
SPECIFICALLY AT. ENCAMPMENTS
THE SENSE. AROUND WHAT THEY
CALLED CLEARING WHICH IN SOME
WAYS SO CASES ISN'T. ALLOWED
IN- THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
LITIGATION THIS IS ABOUT SORT
OF. MAKING IT AS CLEAN AS
POSSIBLE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES RIGHT OKAY WELL
SO TO THE EXTENT YOU ALL NEED-
IF FURTHER ASSISTANCE PLEASE
LET US KNOW BECAUSE I KNOW IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IT'S
BECOMING A HUGE ISSUE BUT
HOPEFULLY THIS PRODUCTIVITY
WILL. START TO SHOW PROGRESS
THIS YEAR AND GET THINGS OUT
THE DOOR SO THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE AND CANDICE SO
EVERYBODY'S CLEAR THE STORM
WATER. LATER PIECES A SEPARATE.
PIECE THAT'S GONNA COME LATER
ON THAT. ONE FOLLOW UP QUESTION
THIS IS. FORTY THREE MILLION
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY-
THOUSAND. INCREASE OR PERMANENT
INCREASED BY. TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
EXPLAIN TO US HOW THE WEEKEND
MORE PROGRAM WORKS AND THE
SEVERAL COUNTIES HAVE THE IN
RATHER THAN DO IN ST JAIL TIME
YOU CAN DO WE CAN WORK THEY
PICK UP SOME LATER WHAT OF THE
SIZE OF THE PROBLEM THAT YOU
HAVE HOW MUCH OF THAT IS TAKING
CARE CARE OF AND THEIR DAD
WHAT'S THE POTENTIAL FOR THE
NON PARTICIPATING COUNTIES. I
GUESS IN THAT JAIL- THE SHARES
DON'T WANT TO. PARTICIPATE IN A
PROGRAM IN IN WHAT AMOUNTED THE
BUDGET DO YOU NEED YOU KNOW
IT'S THE SIX. FREE LABOR BUT
YOU STILL HAVE TO HAVE SOME
CALTRAIN PEOPLE OUT THERE. A
DEALING WITH THAT. IF ANYBODY
HAS HAS. SO WE DON'T HAVE ALL
THE SPECIFICS OF THOSE
QUESTIONS HOWEVER WE DO WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE VARIOUS
COUNTIES IN DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS ON THEIR- SPECIAL
PROGRAM PEOPLE EFFORTS IN ORDER
TO GET THOSE- INMATES IN ORDER
TO HELP WITH THE CLEANUP
SERVICES IT'S A VERY EFFECTIVE
SYSTEM BECAUSE OF NOT ONLY TO
HELP CLEAN UP THE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM BUT WE ALSO USE- THERE
THERE'S UP OUTSIDE BENEFITS TO
WEAR. THE RECIDIVISM AS FAR AS
THOSE IN MAYES OCCURRING- AS
REDUCING THE SAVE THE STATE-
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS NO JUST
IN THOSE SITUATIONS BUT WE DO
WORK WITH- THE ADOPT A HIGHWAY
PROGRAM WITH- THE DHARMA
CORRECTIONS AND THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES WHEN THEY HAVE THOSE
TYPE OF PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO
HELP US WITH THE CLEAN UP ALONG
WITH OUR MAINTENANCE CREWS AS
FAR AS PICKING UP LITTER ALONG
THE WAY ARE THERE ACTUALLY
SHARE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND COUNTY SAID ON I
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM.
THAT JUST SIMPLY SAY THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO HELP US WITH THIS
STATEWIDE PROP PROBLEM. THAT WE
HAVE ANY. NOT AWARE THAT WE CAN
WE CAN LOOK INTO THAT AND GET
YOU THAT ANSWER YEAH I'D LIKE
TO HAVE THAT LIST- PUBLICLY SO
THAT WE CAN NO WHICH IT ITS
SHARE OF CYNIC. IN THE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES ARE JUST.
YOU KNOW SAYING IT'S NOT MY
PROBLEM. COULD WIN I'D LIKE TO
SHARE THAT WITH THE CHAIR OF
SUB FIVE WHEN THEY COME FOR
MONEY FROM A- AID LEADER LETTER
PICK UP STAND RIGHT USE AN
INMATE'S TO. TO ASSESS WHAT THE
RIGHT THING WITH THE HAVE YOU
KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT. LOW
MATH PROBLEM PEOPLE THAT JUST
HAVE TO DO SOME YOU KNOW TEN
OUT TEN DAYS OF COUNTY JAIL
THEY CAN. THEY CAN SIGN UP FOR
THE WEEKEND WORK PROGRAM SO
THEY COME IN. ON SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY THEY'RE DOING IT THEY
CAN DO IT ANYTIME THEY DO A
MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY OR AND-
OR WHATEVER THAT IS BUT THAT
SAID. I'D LET'S OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT. AND LATER A
BASEMENT. WITH CALTRANS. WE'LL
CLOSE THE PUBLIC CAN WITHHOLD
THAT MATTER OPEN AND MOVED TO
ISSUE NUMBER NINE. WHICH IS
WILDFIRE. LITIGATION THIS IS A-
ONE MILLION SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN THOUSAND PERYEAR FOR
YOUR LIMITED TERM RESOURCE ON
THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT
REQUEST GO AHEAD YES GERMAN
OTHER DEPARTMENTS
TRANSPORTATION IS REQUESTING AN
INCREASE OF ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR FOUR YEAR
LIMIT TERM RESOURCE FOR.
INCREASES IN THE LEGAL
DIVISIONS WORKLOAD RESULTING
FROM WILD FIRE LITIGATION. THE
WORKLOAD FOR SEEN REGARDING
WILDLIFE LITIGATION EXCEEDS THE
LEGAL DIVISIONS EXISTING STAFF.
AND CANNOT BE ABSORBED BY
CURRENT STAFFING LEVELS AND
FUNDING. THERE ARE MULTIPLE
WILDFIRE LITIGATIONS THAT MAY
COINCIDE WITH EACH OTHER DURING
THE DURING THE NEXT YEAR WHAT
THE NUMBER OF PLANES RANGING
FROM SIX HUNDRED TO OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED. TIMELY AND
SUCCESSFUL DEFENSE OF WILDFIRE
LITIGATION WERE REQUIRED
DEDICATED RESOURCES. SPECIFIC
TO THE MEDIA THE METS THANK
CHAIRMAN. AS SIMPSON THOUGHTS.
YES IN REGARD TO THE WELFARE
LITIGATION- WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED A PROPOSAL
TO AUGMENT FUNDING FOR CALTRANS
LEGAL DIVISION- AND OUR
ASSESSMENT WE FOUND THAT
WORKLOAD IS LIKELY TO INCREASE
THE MING FROM ABOUT FOR
LITIGATION AND IT'S WITHIN THE
STATE'S INTEREST A SUFFICIENTLY
FUNDED APARTMENT TO DEFEND ANY
LAWSUIT IN THIS REGARD- HOWEVER
WHEN LOOKING INTO THE SITUATION
FURTHER- WE DO RAISE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE SCORES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT MONITORS IN REGARDS
THE TREE AND BRUSH ENCROACHMENT
WHICH ARE KIND OF A METRIC ON.
HOW WELL CALTRANS IS DOING IN
TERMSOF- MAINTAINING THE BRUSH
ALONG THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
THE SCORES IN RECENT YEARS HAVE
BEEN AROUND SEVENTY- IN A
RECENT REPORT THE DEPARTMENT
INDICATED THAT THEY WOULD LIKE
THE SCORE TO BE AROUND NINETY-
WE HAVE NO INDICATION TO
BELIEVE THAT THE THOSE SCORES
ARE WHAT CAUSED THE FIRE BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTERESTED IN
FIGURING OUT WHAT THOSE CURRENT
SCORES ARE AND HOW CALTRANS IS
INTERESTED IN INCREASING THEM-
WE HAVE A SERIES OF QUESTIONS
AND OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND CAN
ALSO BE FOUND IN YOUR GENDER TO
ASK THE DEPARTMENT. RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE. WE HAVE THAT. I GUESS
WHAT'S GO THROUGH THOSE- THE
AYE YOU KNOW BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS THE LITIGATION SO I
DON'T WANNA WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT THAT YOU'RE
HERE SO WE CAN HAVE A PUBLIC
HEARING I GET THE REQUEST ON
THE LITIGATION PART BUT THE
QUESTION IS THAT HOW DO WE DO
THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IN WE
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HAS IS
DEALING WITH THE HOME WHOLE
MOSAIC OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
FOR YOU HAVE YOU KNOW STATE
LANDS PRIVATELY OWNED LAND
COMMERCIALLY TIMBERED LANDS-
PLANS THAT ARE COMMERCIALLY
CHAMBERED AND JUST HAVE TO BE
HAVE TREES. YOU JUST HAVE OTHER
VEGETATION CHAPARRAL THAT'S
THERE WE KNOW THE CAL FIRE HAS
DOES THE ASSESSMENT AND SAYS
OKAY THIS IS WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO BUT A LOT OF THAT THEY BRING
IN THE LUMBERJACKS IF THEY NEED
TO DO TREAT THINNING AND- THEY
BRING IN. FOLKS THAT DO THAT
THE TWO THAT WORK- AND THEN
THERE'S SOME. COMMERCIAL TIMBER
FOLKS THAT ARE DOING THEIR
REGULAR TIMBER HARVEST PLANS
THAT MAY BE WITHIN THIS IS
OWNED BY THE BY THE- AT THE
CALTRANS IN A WITHIN YOUR- WHAT
IS THE- WHAT IS THE VEGETATION.
LEVEL I MEAN DIDN'T THE
DISTANCE. NINETY FOUR EIGHT
HUNDRED. IN ANY EVENT OUR.
EXPLAIN TO ME HOW THE SYMPHONY
COMES TOGETHER WITH THE
CALTRANS AND CAL FIRE IN THESE
PRIVATE- ENTITIES THAT ARE
DOING BASICALLY THE SAME TYPE
OF WORK WERE REDUCING
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. SO I
THINK I CAN TRY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR- OKAY.
OKAY SO JUST JUST OVERALL THE
LEVEL OF SERVICE GORE'S WHAT WE
USE THAT FOR WITH AND PRIVATE
TRANSPORTATION IS WAIT FOR
DIVISION MADE AS TO VALUE WAIT
HOW WE'RE MAINTAINING. VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES ON THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM PART OF THAT INCLUDES
VEGETATION CONTROL TREE AND
SHRUB CLEAN UP CAT. SO THOSE
LITTLE SERVICE SCORES RANGE
FROM ZERO TO ONE HUNDRED AND WE
IDENTIFY THOSE SCORES BASED ON
WHETHER OR NOT IT PASSES
THERE'S A NEED ORDERS A DIRE
NEED NOR FOR CLEANUP SERVICES
THAT CONTROLS THE
PRIORITIZATION. ON WHAT WORKS
CAN BE DONE. IT'S BASICALLY A
SNAPSHOT IN TIME BETWEEN MARCH
AND AUGUST A WHAT IS NEEDED.
ADD WOULD BASICALLY WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS EVALUATE A
SECOND PORTION OF THE HIGHWAY.
ONE MILE SEGMENTS VERY DETAIL
YOU KNOW I WOULD TRY TO CUT IT
COVERS THAT 20% OF THE- AREA
FOR EVERY REGIONAL EVERY THAT
WE ARE WE MAINTAIN. WITH THAT
SAID WE USE THOSE SCORES TO
PRIORITIZE THE VEGETATION AND
IS TO BE DONE NOW. THE LEVEL
SCORES MAY BE DECLINING A
LITTLE BIT FOR THE PAST COUPLE
YEARS MAILINGS BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN RDIRECTING OUR RESOURCES
FOR WILDFIRE EFFORTS WHICH IS
THE PRIMARY CONCERN FOR OUR
SAFETY PURPOSE FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC AND TO TRY TO PREVENT
WILDFIRES FROM OCCURRING. THE
WHOLE LEVEL OF SERVICE SCORE
HOWEVER IS CONTROLLED BY THE
VEGETATION FROM THE STATEWIDE
EFFORT OKAY AND SO. THERE COULD
BE SOME AREAS WHERE THEY DON'T
POSE AN IMMEDIATE THREAT TO THE
MOTORING PUBLIC OR TO A SAFETY
CONCERNS ON THE HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
THE MORE COSMETIC IN NATURE.
CONSEQUENTLY WE WANT TO DRESS
THOSE BECAUSE THE PRIORITIES
MORE TOWARDS THE SAFETY AEAS
OF THAT DEPARTMENT SO THAT WE
WORK TOGETHER WITH OTHER AREAS
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE
VEGETATION. IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THE SAFETY IS THERE
ANYTHING WITH THESE COSMETIC
AREAS WOULD THEY HAVE A LOWER
SCORE OR WITH THE I MEAN
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
ALLEY OF SUGGESTING SAID HOW DO
YOU. WOULD YOU GOT TO DO TO GET
SCORES UP RIGHT NOW DO YOU HOW
DO YOU GET 290% THE WAY WE DO
THAT IS BASED ON THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE REQUEST THAT WE
RECEIVE. THAT ADDRESS THE
PRIORITIZATION OF THE EFFORT
AND SO THE CAUSE MEDIC AREAS.
IT COULD BE A LIE IN URBAN
AREAS WHERE THE IMMEDIATE
THREAT IS NOT THERE HOWEVER. ON
PUBLIC PERCEPTION. THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF CONCERN THAT
THEY WANT THE VEGETATION
CONTROLLED RIGHTLY SO HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF THE PRIORITY AND THE
AND THE LACK OF OR- THE LOW
RISK AND SAFETY. BILL TRIED TO
SCORE DOWN BECAUSE THAT WORK IS
NOT AGAINST TO IT IMMEDIATELY
AS WE MAY HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
THE NEXT YEAR ROUND THE TAKE A
SNAPSHOT OF WHERE WE ARE WHICH
AGAIN BRINGS LEVELS OF SERVICE
DOWN. HIS PRESUMABLY YOU USING
THE LIMITED FUNDS WE HAVE HERE
TO DO THE HIGH PRIORITY SAID
ARE IN FACT NOBODY'S CALLING
ABOUT IT BUT IT'S A HIGH RISK
GIVEN THE TERRAIN- ADJACENT TO
YOUR RESPONSIBLE AREA IS THAT
MORE OR LESS AT. CENTER STERN.
ON THAT NOTE LET ME JUST. CALL
OUT AND THANK YOU ALL OF FOR
PACIFIC COAST HIGHWAY WORK.
pWHERE SAFETY. BOTH FROM A
DRIVING PERSPECTIVE AND A
WILDFIRE PERSPECTIVE KINDA
COLLIDE. REGULAR RANG
IMPRESSION YOU'VE OF NO BIKE
LANE AND THAT. WE ALL KNOW THE
NUMBER OF. DEATHS IS- SOBERING
ON THAT STRETCH OF HIGHWAY SO.
THERE'S A COMBINATION JUST FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE I KNOW THAT
LIKE IT DOES COME SOMEWHAT
COMMUNITY BASED SOMETIMES AND
THINGS JUST POP UP AND THERE'S
VIGILANT YOU KNOW RESIDENTS WHO
SAY LOOK HERE BUT WHEN YOU GUYS
ACTUALLY PICK UP THE PHONE. AND
THEN GO FOLLOW THROUGH ON IT.
THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT TRUST
EXERCISE AND YOU GUYS BEEN
MEETING THAT DOWN THERE AND I
AND I KNOW THERE'S GOING TO
THERE'S OTHER SPOTS LIKE THAT
ALL OVER THE STATE WHERE.
LITERALLY YOU HAVE. YOU KNOW
THAT CIGARETTE BUT OR WHATEVER
THAT THAT SORT OF. HIGHER RISK
LEADS TO WILDFIRE BUT ALSO YOU
KNOW YOU CAN SAVE LIVES
IMMEDIATELY IN THE PROCESS SO-
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL- THE DAILY-
TALKED ABOUT- GOING FORWARD BUT-
BUT FROM MY ON THE GROUND
EXPERIENCE- PICKING UP THE
PHONE AND HAVING A REALLY.
pCROWDSOURCING SOME OF THESE
ISSUES I THINK WE OUGHT TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE THAT MORE I
THINK RIGHT I'M A THERE'S THE
PEOPLE SORT OF NOTE FIGURE OUT
THE RIGHT THROUGH PUT IN THE
NUMBER TO CALL THEY PICK UP THE
PHONE BUT LIKE HOW DO HOW DO IS
THE PUBLIC'S OR TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS BECAUSE THEY'LL THEY'LL
BE ABLE TO SOMETIMES BEAT YOU
TO THE PUNCH EVEN SO AND HAVE
SOME TO THINK ABOUT BUT THANK.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU FOR
THAT CAUGHT THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENTS ARE STERN AND THANK IN
AN APARTMENT FOR A- LOT OF
SPOTS THAT QUICKLY. IT HELPED
THE SCORES ARE IMPORTANT THE
LEVEL SEVER SCORES ARE
IMPORTANT- BUT IN. THIS AS YOU
MENTIONED THE COSMETIC RELATED-
FACTORS SOMETIMES DRIVE THOSE
SCORES DOWN WE ARE
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO FOCUS ON
THE HIGH RISK AREAS THE HIGH
PRIORITY YEARS. AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO- WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE SO LOCKED INTO YOU KNOW
THE SCORES AND MAKE MAKING SURE
WE- WE ABSOLUTELY NEED- YOU
KNOW NINETY PERCENT. NINETY
SCORE OR WHATEVER WE ARE. OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THE HIGH RISK AREAS
ACROSS THE STATE THE STATE WE
ARE WE ARE. A DEFINITELY-
ADDRESSING DOES AND AS WE CAN
GET TO THOSE. TO THE LOWER
LEVEL SERVICE SCORES WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY GET TO DOES. THAT
MAKE SENSE AND MAYBE THE
LITIGATION WILL GO AWAY
HOPEFULLY. YES LET'S OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER NINE WILDLIFE
LITIGATION. SEEING NO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CLOSE THE MATTER-
THE DIRECTOR. MY GUESS IS. ONLY
SHOCKING YES SIR I WISH I CAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN YOUR
CREW- YOU WERE DONE. THANK YOU
BUT LET'S MOVE OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL. LIKE A REFRESHER ON
THE BUSINESS PLAN NO JUST
KIDDING THIS IS THIS IS. HIGH
SPEED REELS COMING UP THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER TEN WE'RE ONLY THE
TOUGH TALK ABOUT THE I. T.
OFFICE RESTRUCTURING THIS IS A
PREVIOUS MATTER THAT WE BROUGHT
THINGS BASED ON THE AUDIT.
AUDITOR'S REPORT. GOOD TO SEE A-
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER ADDRESS
THAN THE NEW BEARD GRADS.
PLEASE PROCEED FOR A- GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND CENTER
STERN I'M PLEASED TO BE BACK
BEFORE THE SUBCOMMITTEE- I'M
JOINED TODAY BY PATTY THIS
INJURE SHE'S OUR CHIEF
TECHNOLOGY OFFICER THE
AUTHORITY IS REQUESTING TWO
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND
FIFTEEN POSITIONS OF
PROPOSITION ONE EIGHTY BOND
FUNDING. TO INCREASE THE
OPERATIONAL CAPACITIES OF THE
AUTHORITIES I. T. OFFICE THIS
REQUEST IS OFFSET BY A
REDUCTION OF THE EQUAL NUMBER
OF CONSULTANT RESOURCES RESULT
IN A NET SAVINGS OF ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. OF THIS
REQUEST WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
RESOURCES FOR THE AUTHORITIES
IT FUNCTIONS INCREASING ITS
STATE OVERSIGHT CAPABILITIES
REDUCING RELIANCE ON CONTRACTED
RESOURCES AND AS THE GERMAN XIN
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR REPORT. A WE DID LAST
YEAR COME BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IN TRANSITION
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE UP POSITIONS
THAT THE AUDITOR HAD FOCUSED
ON- WE- WE CONTINUE THE EFFORT
TO ADD TO EVALUATE AS A
CONSULTANT RESOURCES TO SEE
WERE APPROPRIATE TO SHIFT TO
STATE STAFF IN THIS. REQUEST IS
BROUGHT TO YOU IN THAT CONTEXT.
YOU KNOW YOU SEE ANY MERIT IN
THIS PROPOSAL. A GOOD MORNING
MEDICARE BRIAN BROWN WITH THE
LA- WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL- IS MISTER
AND IF MENTIONED IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE ACTIONS
TAKEN LAST YEAR TO BEGIN
TRANSFERRING SOME OF THESE.
POSITIONS FROM THE RAIL
DELIVERY PARTNER TO THE
AUTHORITY AS WILL BE CONSISTENT
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
AUDITOR AND- IT DOES ALSO
RESULT IN SOME NET SAVINGS FOR
THESE POSITIONS. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU LET'S OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER TEN IT OFFICE
RESTRUCTURING FOR THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. CLOSE
PUBLIC HEARING. MOTOR HOLD THIS
MATTER OPEN I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET'S BRING UP THE HIGHWAY
PATROL THIS IS A ISSUE NUMBER-
ELEVEN OUR ONE OF OUR FAVORITE
ACCOUNTS THE CONDITION OF THE-
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT.
COMMISSIONER STANLEY GOOD
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE
YOU IN. TALK ABOUT OUR UPCOMING
BUDGET AND WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR SUPPORT- IN
PREPARING US FOR TODAY WE HAVE
A FEW BCP'S WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT MAKE IT THOUGH CEMENTED
BUT I KNOW YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE- CONDITION OF THE NBA
AND WILL. TURN IT OVER TO OUR
PARTNERS FROM DELAY. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BEFORE USE THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT IT'S PRIMARILY FUNDED
BY A VEHICLE REGISTRATION BASE
FEE IS SIXTY DOLLARS AND A C.
H. P. FEE OF TWENTY SIX DOLLARS
BOTH OF THOSE HAVE BEEN AND
FLEX INDEXED TO INFLATION. AS
YOU CAN SEE ON THE PHONE
CONDITION. THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT IS APPROACHING-
INSOLVENCY BY THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE SEVERAL
COST PRESSURES HAVE BEEN PLACED
ON THE ACCOUNT INCLUDING- THE
REAL ID COSTS ANNUAL EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION COSTS ACROSS ALL
DEPARTMENTS EXPAND FROM THE
FUND- AND CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS- GIVEN THAT. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE FUND AS
WE APPROACH THIS OUT YEARS- BUT
IN THE IN THE SHORT TERM THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
SEVERAL- COST SAVING MEASURES
INCLUDING- HAVING DMV CHARGE
FOR ITS COLLECTION OF THE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT FEE
THAT WAS ENACTED BY SB ONE-
WILL WILL BE CHARGING THEIR
COST OF SIX POINT SIX MILLION
ANNUALLY TO THE ROAD
MAINTENANCE AND REAL
REHABILITATION ACCOUNT INSTEAD
OF THE NBA. THAT GIVES US A
LITTLE BIT OF SAVINGS WE'RE
PROPOSING TO FUND CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS- USING PUBLIC
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION FUND AND
WE'RE CONTINUING TO SUSPEND THE
NON ARTICLE NINETEEN GENERAL
FUND TRANSFER FOR THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS. GET INTO A DISCUSSION OF
THE SHE SHIFTING FROM THE
PATIENT CO TO THE- FINANCING
MECHANISM LA- YOU HAVE.
SIGNIFICANT COMMENTS ON THIS-
BUDGET PROPOSAL PLEASE PROCEED.
I'M MISTER CHAIR- SO YES THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED-
SEVERAL PROPOSALS THAT DOES
GIVE- SMALL AMOUNTS OF RELIEF
TO THE COST PRESSURES THAT THE
NBA FACE SAYS- BUT THERE IS THE
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE IN THE NBA
WHERE THE EXPENDITURES ARE-
OUTPACING THE ARE INCREASING AT
A HIGHER RATE THAN THE REVENUES
ARE- AND AS THE AT THE VERY
FINANCES MENTIONED. AT THE FUND
WILL BECOME INSOLVENT BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE WITHOUT
ANY FURTHER ACTION I'M- JUST
MOVING FORWARD THE LEGISLATURE
THESE TO BE MINDFUL OF ANY
ONGOING COMMITMENTS FROM THE
NBA INCLUDING AS YOU SAID
SHIFTING- AT THE FUNDING OF COP
OUTLAY PROJECTS AT. THROUGH
BOND FINANCING OVER CASH
FINANCING BECAUSE IN THE LONGER
TERM- THAT WILL CREATE
ADDITIONAL COST PRESSURES TO
THE FIND I'M- THE LEGISLATURE
ME I NEED TO CONSIDER EITHER.
KIND OF THE LONGER FIX EITHER
INCREASING REVENUES OR REDUCING
OPERATIONAL COSTS BUT OF COURSE
EACH- OPTION HAS ITS TRADE OFFS.
YOU CLARIFY FOR ME I'M ONE OF
THE- RECOMMENDATION SHE MAKE IS
THE INCREASE THE MPA FEES IN
THE INDICATE THAT WE COULD YOU
ESTIMATE THAT WE CAN HAVE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION. IN
ADDITIONAL REVENUE FOR A ONE
DOLLAR INCREASE ON THE BASE
REGISTRATION VEHICLE
REGISTRATION AS WELL AS FIVE
MILLION IF A ONE DOLLAR
INCREASE IN THE DRIVER'S
LICENSE FEE NOW. CAN YOU
CLARIFY FOR US MEAN WE SAY
INCREASES TYPICALLY
LEGISLATURE'S COULD THINK OF A
TWO THIRDS. VOTE RIGHT TO TAKE
IF WE INCREASES BUT IF IT'S
JUST AN INCREASE TO THE ACTUAL
COSTS THAT WE KNOW WHERE IT'S
GOING TO OCCUR. IS THAT AN
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIVITY YOUR
WORD IS THAT WHAT IS AT CHANGE
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE YOU'RE SAYING
STRUCTURALLY WE'RE GONNA BE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. IN FISCAL. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. YES THE- MAYBE
PRACTICE ONE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION IS THAT- WE PUT
BEFORE YOU SOME KIND OF THE
RANGE OF OPTIONS THE
LEGISLATURE WILL NEED TO-
POSSIBLY CONSIDER IN THE FUTURE
AS A NBA COMES AN IMBALANCE
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY RECOMMEND-
THAT. FEED THE FEE INCREASES BE
THE OPTION THAT YOU CHOOSE BUT
IT CERTAINLY WILL BE ONE OF THE
OPTIONS THAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU. OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
BUT MORE SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR
QUESTION I THINK TO THE EXTENT
THAT- FEE INCREASES TIED
SPECIFICALLY TO CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES. AND THE- AN
INCREASE IN VIETNAM IS MEANT TO
ADDRESS THE INCREASE IN STATE
COSTS FOR SERVICE PROVIDED THAT
GENERALLY IN THE STATE
CONSTITUTION WOULD BE
SOMETHING- THAT COULD BE DONE
WITH MAJORITY VOTE- HOWEVER IF
YOU DON'T HAVE THAT- THAT SORT
OF NEXUS THEN. GENERALLY WILL
BE CONSIDER ATTACKS REQUIRE TWO
THIRDS OF IT UNDER THE STATE
CONSTITUTION FINANCE WOULD YOU
HAVE TO SAY ABOUT THE NEXUS
BETWEEN THESE. BRAIN THIS IS MY
WIFE FOURTH HERE HERE. AND
EVERY YEAR WERE TALK ABOUT THE
MV A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IT
SAID. SOMETHING I LOOK FORWARD
TO EVERY MARCH CONTINUING INTO
APRIL- CAN YOU GUYS STRONG
NEXUS. A DENIM MA'AM NOT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I WOULD
SAY THAT THE NEXUS IS QUITE
CLEAR BETWEEN WITH THE
ACTIVITIES- WHAT- REVENUE
INCREASED AND WHAT THE ACTIVITY
SUPPORT. IT IS- OUR
UNDERSTANDING THOUGH THAT A
INCREASE IN THAT THE CITY WOULD
REQUIRE- A TWO THIRDS VOTE
EITHER THE C. H. P. V. OR THE-
THE VEHICLE REGISTRATION FEE
THAT. MATTHEW READ MENTIONED
BEFORE EVEN IF WE CAN SHOW OR
YOU COULD SHOW OR DAILY IT
COULD SHOW THAT IT WAS.
STRICTLY TIED TO THE ACTUAL
SERVICES THAT WERE BEING.
DELIVERED TO THE- MOTORING
PUBLIC. WE BELIEVE SO BUT AND A
LOT OF MOMENTUM NOT A SIMPLE
MAJORITY VOTE. WE WOULD
CERTAINLY- BE INTERESTED IN
EXPLORING WHETHER OR NOT IT
COULD BE- MAJORITY VOTE AS
OPPOSED TO A TWO THIRDS VOTE
SO- YOU KNOW. IF IT'S OKAY WITH
YOU MISTER WE'D LIKE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT AND GET BACK TO
YOU YOUR STAFF YEAH. DE MORGAN
HOLD THE MATTER ANYWAY SO- THAT
WOULD BE WEIRD. CHANGING TIMES
NOW AT THAT WERE IN AND WE KNOW
THIS IS THIS IS THE DEMANDS
ARE. PROBABLY EVEN MORE GIVEN
THE COMPETING POLICY THAT WE
HAVE WITH A LECTURE VEHICLES
AND THAT THE REDUCTION IN THE
INCREASE IN. VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED AND THIS JUST LESS
MONEY COMING IN FROM THE
GASOLINE MOTORING PUBLIC. YOU
CAN. LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER.
THIS IS A PHYSICIAN NUMBER.
ELEVEN THIS IS THE FUN
CONDITION FOR THE- A MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT. I WAS CLOSE
PUBLIC HEARING- WE'LL SEE AGAIN
ON THIS MATTER- BUT WE'RE HOLD
IT OPEN THANK YOU. I LOVE TO
LOOK T YOUR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSAL THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE. HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION FROM THE
PUBLIC BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTION
FUND AND THE NBA FOR VARIOUS-
CAPITAL OUTLAYS. YES SIR WE
HAVE A CAPITAL OUTLAY BCP'S
INCLUDING REPLACEMENT OF TWO
RADIO COMMUNICATIONS TOWERS.
AND THE WORK TO REPLACE FIVE C.
H. B. OFFICES. THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED NO LEADER AND NO
LONGER MEET OUR PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS. OR THE SEISMIC
PERFORMANCE CRITERIA REQUIRED
BY STATE OWNED BUILDINGS. AND
ALSO THE MOVEMENT OF THE SIEGE
BE ASSETS FROM THE CURRENT
CAPITAL ANNEX TO THE NEW SWING
SPACE. OUR COMMUNICATIONS.
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSALS
REQUEST TO POINT I'M SORRY TEN
POINT TWO MILLION. FROM THE
MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT TO FUND THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF TO
MISSION CRITICAL RADIO TOWERS.
ON SOUTH TO SAWTOOTH RIDGE
LEVIATHAN PEAK. WE'RE ALSO
SEEKING THE REAPPROPRIATION OF
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION FOR
CALIPARI AT TOWER CONSTRUCTION
PHASE THIS TOWER PROVIDES
COVERAGE IN WEST IN SAN
BERNARDINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES. THE OLD TOWER
COLLAPSE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND
HAS NOT BEEN SALVAGEABLE. THE
THREE- OF OUR PROJECTS FOR AREA
OFFICES SANTA FE SPRINGS
BALDWIN PARK. AND THE QUINCY
AREA ARE IN THE DESIGN BILL
FACE. THE GOAL RUN AREA OFFICE
IS IN THE ACQUISITION PHASE AND
WE ARE SEEKING FUNDING FOR BOTH
PERFORMANCE CRITERIA AN
ACQUISITION PHASE FOR THE
HUMBOLDT AREA OFFICE. PLACEMENT.
THESE PROJECTS ARE TOTAL A
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE PUBLIC
BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTED. AND FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE IN THE
A- NOW FOR THE SANTA SANTA FE
SPRINGS AREAS FORTY FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FALL IN
PARK. FORTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS AND THE QUINCY
AREA OFFICE IS THIRTY EIGHT
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS. THE
GOLD RUN EVERY AREA OFFICES ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION FROM THE NBA
TO FUND THE ACQUISITION PHASE
OF THE PROJECT. AND FROM THE
HUMBOLDT OFFICE TWO POINT ONE
MILLION FROM ME IN THE EIGHT ON
THE ACQUISITION OF PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA PHASE OF THE PROJECT.
WE'RE ALSO SEEKING. FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE NBA FOR STATEWIDE PLANNING
INSIDE IDENTIFICATION AS PART
OF OUR ONGOING EFFORT TO
REPLACE OLDER FACILITIES. THE
NO LONGER MEET OUR DEPARTMENTS
NEEDS FOR SEISMIC SAFETY
STANDARDS. AND THE LAST PART OF
OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY IS THE
CAPITAL SWING SPACE. WE'RE ALSO
ASKING FOR ONE TIME FUNDING ONE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FROM THE NVA TO FUND THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE MANDATORY
RELOCATION. OF C. H. P. ASSETS
IN THE CAPITAL ANNEX TO THE
CAPITAL SWINGS BASE BUILDING.
CURRENTLY UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
THE MOVE IS NOT A TEMPORARY ONE.
ALL SEIZE THE OPERATION IS
CURRENTLY HOUSE IN THE ANNEX
BUILDING WILL BE PERMANENTLY
MOVED TO THE NEW SWING SPACE.
THIS INCLUDES THE CHP PERMIT
OFFICE AND OUR CAPITAL
COMMUNICATION CENTER. THE COST
TO MOVE THE SEIZE PRE RESOURCES
FROM THE ANNEX TO THE NEW
SWINGS BASED INCLUDE THE PROPER
UNINSTALL. THE MOVEMENT AND
STAND UP HOPE OF PUBLIC SAFETY
RADIO SYSTEMS ARE NINE ONE ONE
CALL TAKING EQUIPMENT. AND
ASSOCIATED INTERNET AND PHONE
SERVICES. THE TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE TO MOVE THIS
EQUIPMENT IS OUTSIDE OF OUR
DEPARTMENT AND- RIGHT NOW WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH. CARILLO YES
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS
DIVISION. WHO WILL ULTIMATELY
FACILITATE THE WORK ASSOCIATED
WITH MOVING THE COMMUNICATIONS
EQUIPMENT. WE. WHEN YOU MOVE
OUT OF THE ANNEX INTO THE SWING
SPACE I GUESS THERE'S NO PLAN
IS JUST AS PART OF THE
DEMOLITION THAT'S COULD OCCUR
TO THE ANNEX BUILDING CORRECT
YES THAT'S NOT GONNA BE BACK
FILLED WHAT. UNDER PERFORMING
STAFF NO JUST KIDDING THIS
CARRYING. ALL RIGHT QUESTION I
THINK THE PREVIOUS HEARINGS
WE'VE HAD IS YOUR YOUR- BECAUSE
I TALKED ABOUT JOINT USE ON
SOME OF THESE FACILITIES BUT
THAT WITH OTHER YOU KNOW. CAL
FIRE OTHER STATE AGENCIES THAT
ARE THERE THE END ANSWER HAS
BEEN NO THAT WE LIKE TO HAVE
OUR OWN SPACE. THAT'S THERE
THAT'S- TOTALLY DEDICATED TO
JUST TO SEE HP OPERATION. RIGHT
YES SAID THAT THERE ARE PREVENT
OFFICE THAT- PROVIDES PERMIT
FOR INDIVIDUALS OR- GROUPS THAT
WANT HAVE EVENTS AT THE CAPITOL
AND ALSO OUR- SEIZE PO ARE CALM
CENTER OUR DISPATCH CENTER THAT
DISPATCHES FOR- OUR CAPITAL
PROTECTION SECTION. WHICH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR A- OBVIOUSLY
SECURITY LAW ENFORCEMENT AT THE
CAPITOL AND STATE BUILDINGS IN
AND AROUND SACRAMENTO IN THE
CAPITAL. ON THE SANTA FE IN
BALDWIN PARK IN QUINCY
REPLACEMENTS THOSE- COMPLETE
TEAR DOWNS AND REBUILDING NEW
FACILITIES THOSE WE WILL BE A
NEW FACILITIES- NOT TEAR DOWN
THEY WILL BE COMPLETELY NEW-
SANTA FE SPRINGS WE ACTUALLY-
GOT PROPERTY TRANSFERRED TO US
FROM THE STATE HOSPITALS- WE-
WENT INTO AN AMMO YOU WITH THEM
AND SO WILL BE TAKING OVER.
SOME OF THAT PROPERTY TO BUILD
A SANTA FE SPRINGS AREA OFFICE
THERE AND ACTUALLY THE BALDWIN
PARK SPEECH BE OFFICE. THIS
ALSO IN THE DESIGN AND BUILD
PHASE WE GOT THAT PROPERTY FROM
CAL POLY HI. SO I GUESS WHAT
I'M LOOKING WERE WE'RE LOOKING
AT EXCEPT WERE LITTLE HAVE A
TIME YOU HAVE TO MOVE INTO THE
NEW FACILITY BUT THOSE THOSE
STATE PROPERTIES WOULD BECOME
AVAILABLE TO OTHER STATE
AGENCIES. ONCE YOU GUYS MOVE
OUT IS THAT THE THINKING YES
WHAT WE DO IS WE- BIG- WE MEET
WITH D. G. S. IN THOSE
PROPERTIES GO BACK TO D. G. S.
FOR OTHER- OTHER ENTITIES TO
USE. WITHIN THE STATE AND JUST
WITH REGARD TO SANTA FE PAUL
ONE PARKING QUINCY ARE THESE HI
REFER TROLL OFFICES THAT ARE.
RIGHT ON THE FREEWAY AMY AT
ADJACENT TO THE WAIT STATION OR
THESE HIGHWAY WHICH I DON'T
KNOW WHETHER THEY'RE STATE
AGENCY WOULD WANT TO BE THERE
RIGHT ON THE- ON THE FREEWAY
BUT- OR ARE THEY- WITHIN THE-
YOU KNOW TRADITIONAL. OFF THE
FREEWAY BUT IN THE CITY AREA
OR- ALL THREE OF THOSE ARE A
RIGHT OFF THE FREEWAY- THE-
SANTA FE SPRINGS OFFICE I'M
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT
BECAUSE- SPENT A LOT OF MY
CAREER WORKING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IS THAT IS ADJACENT.
ROUGHLY A QUARTER MILE FROM THE
SIX OH FIVE FREEWAY- THE BALL
IN PARK OFFICE IS RIGHT OFF
THE- RIGHT OFF INTERSTATE TEN-
FRANCISQUITO WHICH IS. ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE FREEWAY IS IN
AND OUT BURGER BUT THERE IS
VERY CLOSE TO THE FREEWAY OKAY
YOU ARE. LA ANYTHING ELSE TO
ADD. THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS
NOT SORRY- I'M SORRY I LIED WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY- CONCERNS ANY
PARTICULAR CAP OUT LATE
PROPOSAL- HOWEVER WE AGREE WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF THAT SHIFTING
FROM CASH FOR FUNDING TO BOND
FINANCING IS OF CONCERN FOR THE
LONGER TERM- AT BECAUSE IT
CREATES ADDITIONAL COST
PRESSURES TO THEM BE. WE AGREE
ARE LET'S OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE CAPITAL OUTLAYS FOR THE-
I WILL CONTROL. THIS CLOSE
PUBLIC HEARING WILL KEEP THIS
MATTER OPEN AND NOW E.
CIGARETTES AND A IT WOULD
APPEAR SITS HERE IS A NEW
ENDEAVOR BY THE C. H. P. TO BE
DOING- AND- INVESTIGATIVE WORK
ON ON THE CIGARETTES BUT PLEASE
GO AHEAD WITH YOUR SOCIAL AND
THE CIGARETTE AND ENFORCEMENT.
WE HAVE A VCP BEFORE YOU THAT
REQUEST TEN POSITIONS AND SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN PERMANENT
AUGMENTATION FROM THE
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE PRODUCTS
TAX FUNDING FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO STAND UP A TASK
FORCE CHARGED WITH COMBATING
ILLICIT VAPING DEVICE AND
PRODUCT IMPORT EXPORT
MANUFACTURING TRANSPORTATION
DISTRIBUTION AND SALES. OR THE
PAST FEW YEARS THE USE OF
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS VAPING HAS
INCREASED GREATLY. THIS NEW
POPULARITY HAS LED TO A MARKET
FOR ILLICIT VAPING DEVICES AND
OTHER COMMODITIES. UNREGULATED
THESE BLACK MARKET PRODUCTS CAN
CONTAIN DANGEROUS ADDED
ADDITIVES FOUND IN BOTH VAPING
LIQUIDS AND IN THE CONSTRUCTION
OF THE DEVICES THEMSELVES. AS
OF DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN THE
CDC PLACES A NUMBER OF THE
CIGARETTE VAPING. SELECT AT USE
ASSOCIATED WITH LONG INJURIES
AT TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
NINETY ONE AND THE NUMBER OF
DEATHS NATIONALLY AND FORTY
EIGHT. TO ADDRESS IS RAPIDLY
INCREASING- USE USE BY USE OF
THIS POTENT NICOTINE BASED
PRODUCTS THE PROPOSED BUDGET
SEEKS A NEW NICOTINE CONTENT
BASE THE CIGARETTE TAX. THE NEW
TAX WILL BEGIN ON JANUARY OF
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IT WILL
ADD TWO DOLLARS FOR EACH FORTY
MILLIGRAMS OF NICOTINE IN THE
PRODUCT. THE TAXI WILL BE USED
FOR ADMINISTRATION ENFORCEMENT
YOU PREVENTION AND HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE PROGRAM. OUR PROPOSAL
LEVERAGES THE OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND UNIFORMED OFFICERS
THIRTY FOUR STATIONERY
COMMERCIAL VEHICLE INSPECTIONS
AND ARE NEARLY FOUR MILLION
CONTACTS IN THE SIEGE BE
SPECIALIZED INVESTIGATIONS TEAM
DELETED TASK FORCE IN
COOPERATION WITH THE DOJ TO
PROVIDE FOCUSED ENFORCEMENT.
WITH THE INTENT TO INVESTIGATE
AND DISRUPT THE FLOW OF ILLICIT
VAPING DEVICES AND PRODUCTS
BEING DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS AN
INITIAL FOUNDATION FOR THE
PROGRAM WE'RE ASKING FOR ONE
SERGEANT TO SUPERVISE A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM AND NINE
OFFICERS BEFORE SPECIALIZED
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS AND
ENFORCEMENT. TARGETING ILLICIT
VAPING DEVICES- PRODUCT IMPORT
EXPORT MANUFACTURING
TRANSPORTATION. DISTRIBUTION
AND SALES WE PROPOSE THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION OF THE SEVEN
MILLION BE ALLOCATED FOR
CONTRACTING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO DATE AS WITH
THESE EFFORTS. WE HAVE RECEIVED
A LETTER COMMITMENT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ENDORSING
THIS EFFORT AND SUPPORTING PCP.
THE CEASE BEING A DOJ HAVE A
HISTORY OF WORKING TOGETHER
WITH SPECIALIZED TASK FORCES
FOR FORSMAN EFFORTS. THIS
PROPOSAL COMBINES THE UNIQUE
STRENGTH OF BOTH OUR
DEPARTMENT. AND LEVERAGES ARTS
EXPERTISE AND RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. WHICH HAS
BEEN LABELED AN EPIDEMIC BY
SOME. I GUESS COMMISSIONER
STANLEY THE QUESTION ISWHY THE
CHP IN THIS AREA THAT YOU'VE
NEVER DONE AND WHY WOULD YOU
NOT DEVELOP A GRANT PROGRAM
THAT YOU WOULD USE EXISTING
LOCAL POLICE. THAT THEY DID
THEY HAD REMEMBER WHEN THEY WE
HAD A GRANT PROGRAM WHERE THEY
WOULD HAVE SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
SAID LOOK LIKE THIRTY YEAR OLDS
WALK IN AND TRY TO BUY
CIGARETTES WHEN I WAS EIGHTEEN
AND THAT WAS- YOU KNOW YOU HAD.
TONS THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
THAT WANTED TO PARTICIPATE IN
DEBT AND GET SOME MONEY SO THAT
THEY COULD HAVE THE TECH GIVES
OR WHOEVER WHOEVER'S THE PEOPLE
THAT DO THAT. THAT TYPE OF WORK
ONE WELL I'LL TALK ABOUT WHEN
HE SEES P. IN IN IN THAT SECOND
I HAVE- ASSISTANT CHIEF. HONDA
RATE TALK ABOUT. WHAT THE
LOCALS ARE DOING WHY THE SIEGE
BE STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION WHICH
WERE IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES- HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE PERSONNEL THAT WORK IN
VARIOUS TASK FORCES SEE TIP-
COMMERCIAL- IN FORCING A TASK
FORCE INTERFERE FOREIGN EXPORT
IN RECOVERY. AND THEY'RE OUT
THERE IN THE FIELD EVERY DAY
COMING ACROSS- PRODUCTS- THAT
HAVE BEEN STOLEN OR THAT ARE
ILLEGAL. AND WE ARE ABLE TO
INTERCEPT THESE COMMODITIES
ARREST THOSE PEOPLE. WHO ARE
COMMITTING. THESE CRIMES.
RECENTLY WE STARTED THE
ORGANIZED RETAIL RETAIL PASSED
TASK FORCES. THERE ARE THREE IN
THE STATE ONE IN SAN FRANCISCO
ONE IN LA. AND ONE IN SAN DIEGO
TO COMBAT THE RETAIL THAT THAT
IS GOING ON IN THOSE TASK
FORCES. HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL AND WE'VE- ALSO
WORKING WITH LOCAL DJS AND
LOCAL PT'S INSURERS. ARE ON
THOSE TASK FORCES TO- TO COMBAT
THOSE CRIMES AND WE FEEL-
TAKING THAT APPROACH WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO. HAVE AN IMPACT
BEING THAT WE'RE STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION. BECAUSE THESE
ARE- LEGAL DEVICES IN HIS
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY WHICH IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT. AND PLAN
ASSISTANT CHIEF DRAPER TALK
ABOUT WHAT THE LOCALS ARE DOING
WITH SOME OF THAT GRANT MONEY
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IT BUT
THAT THE- LA- SUGGESTED WE
LEARN A LITTLE ABOUT. THE
GEOGRAPHIC CONCENTRATION IT OR
THAT THE SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM
AND THAT SOME OF THIS MAY BE
LIMITED RATHER IN ALL FIFTY
STATES MAY BE LIMITED IN TO
CERTAIN TARGET AREAS. THAT THE
MONEY COULD BE USED RATHER THAN
HAVE EVERY C. H. P. OFFICER
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. OR NOT
EVERY TEN PICK TEN POSITIONS
DOING IT- THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
THIS IS MORE FOLK. A ON WHEN WE
WERE WE THINK THIS ILLICIT
MARKET IS THAT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRED NUMBER THREE
CHIEF THAT'S A PROMOTION
ASSISTANT CHIEF BUT APPRECIATE
IT UP TO YOU TO HEAR THE- THIS.
IS A GOOD MORNING MY NAME
CHANDERI ON THE ASSISTANT CHIEF
FOR THE CHP IN THE DEPARTMENTS
LEGISLATIVE LIAISON- THE
QUESTION AS TO WHY IN SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS YOU'RE BRINGING
UP A TO BE HONEST I WAS OUR
FIRST QUESTION TWO MORE
APPROACH WITH THIS PROPOSAL BUT
AS WE LOOKED AT IT. AND THE
ANSWER IS PRETTY CLEAR TO US IF
ONE WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
EFFORTS OF DEPARTMENT HEALTH
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
LOCALS AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
BUT WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
ADDRESSING THE ILLICIT OR BLACK
MARKET EFFORTS THAT ARE OUT
THERE LAST YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND TWENTY PROPERTY
SIX AFFORD OVER THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS AWARDED TO
GRANTS OVER SEVENTY SIX
DIFFERENT AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THEIR EFFORTS
ALTHOUGH WHILE- IMPORTANT ARE
FOCUSED ON REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT- WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BY BUS WITH
MINORS WHICH ARE OTHERWISE
LEGAL- PRODUCTS THAT THEY'RE
BUYING WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BRIDGING THE GAP THAT FROM WHAT
WE KNOW IS NOT BEING ADDRESSED
IN THAT GAP WOULD BE WITH THE
ILLICIT. THE LEGAL THE BLACK
MARKET THE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
THAT'S GOING ON OUT THERE. AND
EXPERTS BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
WHERE THE INJURIES THAT'S FOR
THE DESKS AND THAT'S WHERE THE-
THE PROBLEM LIES AS THE TAXES
AND LEGAL COMMODITIES ARE TAXED
WE BELIEVE THAT THE BLACK
MARKET MORE PEOPLE CAN BE
DRIVEN TOWARDS THAT SO THE
PROBLEM ON THE BLACK MARKET THE
LIST OF PRODUCTS ARE GONNA.
RISE THAT'S WHERE THE SIEGE BE
DOES HAVE EXPERT THAT'S YOU
KNOW LEVERAGING THE- THE SEVEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE HIGHWAY
PATROL AND I KNOW WE DON'T WANT
ALL GOING TO BE AN EXPERT BUT
WE DO ON ALL OF THEM TO BE
FOCUSED ON THIS WE DO WANT ALL
OF THEM WHEN THEY'RE IN A
TRAFFIC STOP TO RECOGNIZE OKAY
THIS COULD BE. ILLEGAL PRODUCT
LAST YEAR WE RECOVERED OVER
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND POUNDS OF
ILLICIT DRUGS- I DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE BUT I WOULD BE WILLING TO
BET THAT THE LARGEST SEIZURE BY
ANYONE AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
WE WOULD TAKE OUR EXPERTISE
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT GOING
INTO KEEPING A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD
FROM BUYING A PRODUCT THAT
THOSE EFFORTS WITH THE LEGAL TO
DO MORE TALK ABOUT BRIDGING
THAT GAP. AND PERHAPS
INTERCEPTING SHIPMENTS
TRUCKLOADS COMING INTO OUR
PORTS AND SEIZING HE WE GO
PRODUCT BEFORE GETS DISTRIBUTED
TO THE STATE. WELL YOU HAVE
SOME THOUGHTS ON THIS MATTER.
SORRY THANK YEAR ANSWERS HERE
SO WE DEFINITELY BELIEVE THAT
TAKING ACTION ON AND- ILLICIT
VAPING PRODUCTS IS LAUDABLE AND
GIVEN THE SERIOUS HEALTH
CONCERNS VERY IMPORTANT.
HOWEVER AS YOU MENTIONED WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL AND IN PARTICULAR AS-
AS DEPARTMENT MENTIONED THE
PROBLEM IS VERY- AND THERE'S A
LOT OF UNKNOWNS WITH THE
PROBLEMS SO- AS YOU MENTIONED
THERE. IS THAT AND CERTAINTY
AROUND THAT YOU EAT JAGA FEE OF
THE PROBLEM WHETHER IT IS
REALLY A STATE WIDE OR
CONCENTRATION ISSUE THERE IS
ALSO. AT N UNCERTAINTY AROUND
KIND OF. ALL THE ALL THE ISSUES
THAT ARE INTER CONNECTED WITH
THE VAPING HEALTH PROBLEMS SO
IS IT REALLY A YOU KNOW A USE
NICOTINE AND ISSUE WHERE. THAT
THAT YOU KNOW THAT IS PART OF
THE PROBLEM BUT ALSO IN
ADDITION TO THAT. THE ADDITIVES
THAT ARE IN THE ILLICIT
CANNABIS PRODUCTS I'M- AND ONCE
WE HAVEN'T KIND OF HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
PROBLEM AND THE LEGISLATURE MAY
BE ABLE TO. DECIDE ON AN
APPROPRIATE TIME STRATEGY THAT
MAY MOST EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM SO IF IT REALLY IS
A STATE WIDE ENFORCEMENT
STRATEGY THAT YOU MAY WANT TO
PURSUE THAN A SPEECH HE MAY BE
THE MOST APPROPRIATE- GIVEN
THEIR CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIVE
BACKGROUND- BUT THERE'S ALSO
OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT DO HAVE-
KIND OF MORE CONTENT EXPERTISE
FOR EXAMPLE- PURE OF CANDACE
CONTROL HAS KIND OF THE
REGULATORY UNDERSTANDING OF-
ILLICIT CANNABIS PRODUCTS AND-
THAT MAY BE. AB YOU KNOW
CONTACTS WITH THESE THAT YOU
MAY ALSO WANT TO LEVERAGE IN
THE TASK FORCE IF STATEWIDE
ENFORCEMENT IS AS- IS AND WHAT
YOU BELIEVE IS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE STRATEGY. AND THEN
AND SO. I THINK ONCE THERE IS A
BIT MORE- UNDERSTANDING OF THE
UNKNOWNS REGARDING THE ISSUE
AND ITS CONNECTION TO THE
HEALTH EPIDEMIC THEN. THE
LEGISLATURE CAN MOST DAM.
CREATE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS THE SERIOUS
HEALTH CONCERN. THANK YOU ACT
CAN CAN YOU CLARIFY MEMBER JUST
COMMENT ON THAT THE
COORDINATION QUESTION WITH YOUR
CAMPUS CONTROLLING JUST HOW YOU
ALL ENVISIONED THAT SHAKING
OUT. AND LIKE. CAN DISSIPATE AT
THIS POINT FROM WHAT YOU KNOW
THE LOT OF THE ACTIVITY. IS A
VERY GOOD IT'S SORT OF GOING
AFTER SHIP MEN TRAFFICKING
ISSUES IS THIS IS THIS STUFF
THAT'S ON THE ROAD AND THAT'S
THE INTERVENTION POINT ARE YOU
LOOKING AT SPECIFIC THEY CAN
EVEN GOING AT THE RETAIL SIDE
OF IT AND TRY TO COORDINATE
THAT WITH YOUR A CANNABIS
CONTROL CAN USE LIKE JUST.
FLUSH OUT HOW HOW YOU COULD SEE
THE NEXT YEAR TRANSPIRE WITHOUT
OBVIOUSLY TIPPING YOUR HAND
AND- DISCLOSING WHATEVER YOUR
STRATEGY IS GOING TO BE- BIG
PART OF THE STRATEGY IS WAS
WORKING WITH DOJ AS WE HAVE
WORK WITH THEM AND OTHER TASK
FORCES THROUGHOUT THE STATE ONE
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS OUR-
SPECIAL OPERATIONS UNIT AND-
WITH. THE TECHNOLOGY THAT WE
HAVE WITH THE **** THAT WE HAVE
WITH OUR INVESTIGATIVE SKILLS
WORKING TOGETHER- WITH DOJ WE
FEEL WE BE ABLE TO- YEAH WE CAN
INTERCEPT THEM ON THE ROAD. IN
A RETAIL ESTABLISHMENTS AND
WORK THOSE CRIMINAL CASES NOW
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
LEARNED THROUGH SOME OF THE
RESEARCH THAT WE HAVE DONE ALL
THE TIME WE IN A LITTLE BIT
MORE. IS THAT YOU KNOW. A GOOD
PORTION IS CARS ON THE
INTERNET. AND WE HAVE WHAT WE
CALL OUR COMPUTER CRIMES
INVESTIGATIONS UNIT WHICH IS-
MADE ABOUT THE LIEUTENANT-
SERGEANT IN EIGHT OFFICERS AND
SOME. CIVILIAN I. T. PERSONNEL
AND THIS IS WHAT THEY DO IS
THEY HLP US OUT WITH COMPUTER
CRIMES- CASES THEY HELP IS TO-
INTERNET SEARCHES OR-
ESPECIALLY WITH THAT YOU KNOW
PETA FILES AND- AND THOSE KIND
OF THINGS EIGHT THEY CAN DO A
LOT OF WORK FOR US THAT WOULD.
HELP US IN THAT IN THAT ARENA
SOME OF THIS IS GOING ON. I
WOULD ADD WHAT WE AGREE WITH
THE LA- IN THE FACT THAT WE
REALLY DON'T KNOW BECAUSE
NOBODY'S REALLY. WORKING IN
THIS AREA OF ILLICIT BLACK
MARKET ENFORCEMENT SO WE REALLY
DON'T KNOW THE PROBLEM OF THE
PROBLEM AND- TO YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR. WE DO HAVE A GOOD
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
CAMPUS CONTROL NOW WHEN IT
COMES TO. CANNABIS AND THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THAT SO WE WOULD
ABSOLUTELY LEVERAGE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND THEIR-
EXPERTISE. AND THEN- TO THE
QUESTION IS IT BEING OPERATED
ON THE HIGHWAYS IN TRANSPORT
ABSOLUTELY EVERY SHIPMENT THE
YOU KNOW IT'S COMING IN THE
UNITED STATES MOST IMPROBABLY
THROUGH. OUR PORTS- IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN GETTING
SHIPPED IN AND THAT'S PROBABLY
WHY THE FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
POUNDS- I SAID YOU KNOW.
MENTIONED EARLIER IT'S BECAUSE
WE ARE OUT THERE ON THE
HIGHWAYS AND WE ARE MAKING FOUR
MILLION PUBLIC CONTACTS YEARS
SO. IT IN SO. MANY IN TERMS OF
I KNOW WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO. ON
ON ON THE BCC SIDE TRYING TO.
M. DEAL WITH SOME OF THE
TESTING BOTTLENECKS AND IN
TERMS OF SOURCING SPECIALLY ON
IN THAT CANNABIS VAPING MARKET
RIGHT IDENTIFYING. THE ORIGIN.
IS BECOMING SOMEWHAT EASIER IN
STATE ALTHOUGH THERE'S STILL
GROWS THAT HAPPENED ILLEGALLY
ALL OVER THE PLACE THERE'S A
LOT OF. OTHER INTERVENTION
EFFORTS THERE BUT ARE YOU YOU
ARE USE SORT OF SUGGESTING THAT
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE REALLY
TOUGH TO GET THAT PRODUCT THE
REALLY DANGEROUS STUFF THAT'S
RESULTING IN THESE THESE HEALTH
CRISES. MAYBE COME IN FROM
OUTSIDE OF OUR BORDERS IN OTHER
WORDS. YET IT WOULD BE
PREMATURE COMMENT ON THE
SPECIFICS OF IT WE DO KNOW IN
OUR PRELIMINARY RESEARCH THAT A
LOT OF- AND I'VE QUICKLY BECOME
MORE KNOWLEDGE ONE DAY CAN I
NOTICE HER BEFORE- THIS BUT-
YOU KNOW THEY'RE SHIPPING THESE
CONTAINERS THAT YOU ACTUALLY
THE VIALS OR WHATEVER THAT AND
THEN THEY'RE BEING FILLED HERE.
AND CALIFORNIA BY DIFFERENT
PEOPLE AND SO YOU KNOW IF WE
COULD INTERCEPT THOSE ILLEGAL
SHIPMENTS A CONTAINERS THINK
ABOUT MONEY- VAPING. ILLEGAL
ONES WE COULD TAKE UP THE
STREETS AND THOSE ARE WORTHY
EASILY OR THE- DANGEROUS
CHEMICALS AND STUFF FOR BEING
INTRODUCED BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
REGULATED. I SEE SO THE ACTUAL
IGNITION DEVICES AND THE
CARTRIDGES IN THIS SORT OF
THOSE PRODUCTS. ARE SIGNIFICANT
RISK IN ADDITION TO THE ACTUAL.
SAID A- PESTICIDE TREATED-
TOBACCO OR OR- CANNABIS ITSELF
THAT UPON COMBUSTION BECOMES.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY. AND I THINK
OUR FOCUS WOULD BE INSTEAD OF
GOING TO THE END OF THE ROW AND
GETTING THE END USER THAT'S
BUYING IT ILLEGALLY TO GOING TO
THE SUPPLY CHAIN TO DISRUPTING
THE CRIMINAL IN PRICE IT'S
BEHIND IT TO GOING TO THE LEGAL
SURPRISE OUR- SUPPLIERS. ONLINE
USE IN OUR- OUR COMPUTER CRIMES
UNITS TO IDENTIFY THESE FOLKS
AND- THANKS. APPOINTMENTS
FINANCE THE AS- ELLIE- SUGGESTS
IS THAT QUESTIONS WEATHERED CHP
IS THE APPROPRIATE AGENCY TO
LEAD THIS ANTENNA LISTED VAPING
NO EFFORT. GOVERNOR'S CHOSEN
THEM CAN YOU GIVE US YOUR
THINKING OR GOVERNOR'S THINKING
ON THIS OF. THE MATTER STANDING
IN THE GOVERNOR'S THINKING
ASSOCIATES P. LET WILL BE ABLE
TO LEVERAGE I BELIEVE. THAT
NIGHT DEPUTY CHIEF ASSISTANT
CHIEF TERRY MENTIONED THE
NUMBER OF COULD STATE WHAT
CONTACTS THAT THEY HAVE TO THE
GENERAL IDEA IS THAT IF YOU
WERE TO PROVIDE. GRANTS TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT- THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO RIDE THE
LIMITED AMOUNT OF FORCE IN OVER
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME- FOR THE
AMOUNT THE AVAILABLE BY THE
GRANTS IF YOU'RE ABLE TO-
LEVERAGE THE- NINE DIFFERENT
OCCASIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
FOR TEN EIGHT FILLED HIS EIGHT
FEEL DIVISIONS EXCUSE ME IN.
THEN I THINK HERE IN
HEADQUARTERS- BUT A DIFFERENT
DIVISIONS SO YOU HAVE ONE
OFFICER IN EACH OF THOSE
DIVISIONS OF THE INITIAL PLAN
THE IDEA WOULD BE TO LEVERAGE
THOSE CONTACTS- THAT THE
OFFICERS MAKE IN THE FIELD. IF
AN OFFICER IDENTIFIES SOMETHING
FISHY- YOU MAYBE YOU- THAT
OFFICER WOULD LIKELY BE TO
CONTACT THE- LEAD OFFICER IN
THAT DIVISIONS THAT WE WOULD
HAVE A STATEWIDE PRESENCE
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING. I TO THE
ALEJO'S POINT THERE'S A LOT
THAT'S NOT KNOWN ABOUT THIS AND
SO THE IDEA WOULD BE TO BEGIN
TO GET A BASE OF UNDERSTANDING
AT THAT POINT MAKE BETTER
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT
THE BEST A FORCE BEEN STRATEGY
WOULD BE. I THINK THEY'RE
MAKING THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
THE HIGHER PATROL HAVING A
PIECE OF THE SOLVING THE
ILLICIT PROBLEM AND BEING THE
LEADER OF SOLVING THE LIST OF
PROBLEMS THAT THERE'S A
DISTINCTION OTHER STATE
AGENCIES THAT HAVE BEEN
SUGGESTED. LET'S OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN THE E.
CIGARETTE TAX ENFORCEMENT.
PLEASE GOOD MORNING KELLY BEAM
OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND POSITIONS IN THE
STATE AND I DON'T OFTEN FIND
MYSELF IN THE RESOURCES UP SO
THANK YOU- BUT WE ARE VERY
MUCH. IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED EASE
CIGARETTE TAX AND ALSO THIS
ENFORCEMENT COMPONENT. IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THE NATIONAL
OUTBREAK IN THE FALL- SHED
LIGHT ON HOW VAPING WHETHER
CANNABIS OR TOBACCOIS
IMPACTING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OVERALL. WE ARE STILL LEARNING
ABOUT THIS NEW NIMBLE
TECHNOLOGY AND INDUSTRY. AND I
JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE TO IT'S
NOT JUST CHILDREN BUT ADULTS
ARE AFFECTED AS WELL DURING
THAT OUTBREAK THERE A LOT OF
ADULTS WHO ARE KEEPING PRODUCTS
THAT THEY GOT ONLINE AND- LIKE
THE TESTIMONY EARLIER. THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW
THERE WAS THIS BIG UPRISING OF
ALL THE CASES BUT WHEN AND WHEN
THEY DRILL DOWN TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT PRODUCTS THEY RE USING A-
WAS A LOT. OF WHERE. THE JEWS
HAD BEEN DISTILLED AND THE
CANNABIS OR TOBACCO ADDED- WITH
OTHER CHEMICALS THAT ARE NOT
USED HERE IN THE STATES.
IMPLEMENTING A TAX ON E.
CIGARETTES AND THEIR LIQUIDS
WITH STAMPS SO SIMILAR TO
COMBUSTIBLE CIGARETTES ARE DONE
NOW MAY DRIVE MORE THE MARKET
UNDERGROUND AS WAS NOTED
EARLIER WHETHER MATERIALS
INCLUDED IN LIKE WITH ARE NOT
REGULATED AT ALL. AND THEY THE
IMPORT USING DRUMS OF LIQUID
AND THEN THAT GOES DIFFERENT
SHOPS AND THEY YOU CAN USE IT
YOU CAN BUY A BOTTLE- AND THE
SHOP CAN PUT IN WHATEVER THEY
WANT TO BE HONEST WITH YOU- AND
THEN THE CONSUMER BUYS THAT AND
THEY CAN INSERTED INTO AN OPEN
SYSTEM SO. AS OPPOSED TO A
JEWEL- CARTRIDGE WITH A POD-
THE INDUSTRY HAS CHANGED A LOT
WITH THE FLAVOR BàN AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL SO NOW KIDS ARE
PIVOTING TO DISPOSABLE. E.
CIGARETTES WHERE THEY CAN GET
WHATEVER FLAVOR THEY WANT
BECAUSE THERE WAS A CAR ABOUT
FOR DISPOSABLES. AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE INDUSTRY IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND THIS IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. TO HELP
MITIGATE THE I KNOW. SORRY YES
TO MITIGATE THE POTENTIAL
EXPANSION OF THE UNDERGROUND
MARKET BEFORE IT HAPPENS. THIS
PROPOSAL FOR STATEWIDE EFFORT
TARGETING THE ILLICIT MARKET BY
THE CHP COUPLED WITH LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT HURTING YOU'VE
CONSUMPTION AND POSSESSION. AND
THE SHOPS THE LOCAL SHOPS.
PUBLIC HEALTH CAMPAIGNS AND A
POTENTIAL BAN FLAVOR TOBACCO
PRODUCTS WILL ALL WORK TOGETHER
INFORMATION ABOUT THE INDUSTRY
AND AFFECT CONSUMER BEHAVIOR
POSITIVELY. IN THE LONG RUN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL CLOSE
THE PUBLIC HEARING-
COMMISSIONER STANLEY AND
ASSISTANT CHIEF- DURING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL- CLERK WILL
HOLD THE MATTER OPEN. CALL OF
THE- THE DMV AND- THEIR BUDGET
OFFICERS GIVE ME TWO MINUTES.
WHEN THE. TO MAKE IT. OR HE
DIDN'T QUITE GET THE GRANT. I
GET THE- WHAT DOES. THE FIVE
THAT. ONE HUNDRED THIRTY. YEAH
I HAVE YEAH.
IF YOU CAN
EDUCATION. OF THE ONE OF. IF
YOU CAN. THE TOP OF MY HEAD.
FOR I WANT WALKING. YEAH. THAT
IF YOU. REALLY FIFTY DEPARTMENT.
I AM VERY. THIS IS ONE. YEAH
THAT. A DICE MICHAEL. ALL
PORTIONS. HEARING COULD KEEP.
WHICH YEAH TO THE TICKET WE CAN
STOP THEM. WHICH MIGHT EXPLAIN
BUT US YEAH LIKE BUT. THE TWO.
THAT'S SOMETHING YEAH YEAH.
THIS IS THE HALF HOME I'M
PRETTY PROMOTED TO AND IT'S-
SELECT COMMITTEE WHICH THIS IS
OF THE SUPREME OVER YEAH BUT
WHAT IT A HEALTHY IS. SIX
TWENTY TWENTY. IF YOU. AT A
TIME TO PAY THAT KIND OF SOUNDS
KIND. YEAH AVAILABLE IN THE
STORE LIKE THAT YOU KNOW THE
TWENTY. THIS IS. TWENTY AND HE
SAID. SO WHEN YOU NEVER FORGET
MY ANNIVERSARY THAT WE ONLY
REMEMBER MY BURKE. ARE YOU. SO
IF SOMEONE IS A COMPLETE. TO
THANK THEY LOOK AT THE GREAT
DAY THE- AT THE LABOR BACK ON A
RECORD. MISS SCOTT GOOD MORNING
CATHY HAVE A- NOW WEB. BUT NICE
SEE YOU NICE HE TO SORRY GOT TO
THIRTY WE ARE ON YOUR CAPITAL
PROPOSALS ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
PLAY PROCEED A GOOD MORNING A
CHAIR MICHAEL AND MEMBERS I AM
THE SCOTT IN A CHIEF BUDGET ALL
BUT THE DEPARTMENT VEHICLES AND
WITH TODAY IS THE YOU'VE W. CAL
WEB. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY ADDRESS THE TODAY
US DEPARTMENT DOES HAVE TO ON
THE A I'D LIKE TO A QUICK
OVERVIEW OF AND IT'LL BE HAVE
TO ANSWER. SO FOR THE FIRST
ISSUES NUMBER FOURTEEN DMV
CAPITAL PROPOSAL. BERMAN HAS
THREE CAN. CAN OUTLAY. THAT ARE
PROPOSED TO BE FUN FROM THE PA.
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION FUND.
THESE PROPOSALS UP ON THE COUCH
PHASE OF THE- A BUILT ON
REPLACE FOR. AND THE LANE L.
BRIEFLY. ANSWERED MARIA.
TOTALING BUDGET OVER OF ROUGHLY
POINT MILLION. THE IS ALSO A
FOR POINT SIX NO FROM THE MORE
VEHICLE IT. TO CONTINUE TO PRE
APPROVED OX FIELD OFF. WE CAN.
PRO STAR THE FIRST PHASE OF THE
FRANCISCO UP A REPLACE PROJECT.
AND OF ON STAGE WIDE PLAN AND
FIGHT ITEM WHICH FOR CAP OUTLAY
REQUEST. OF THAT IS WHAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW IF YOU ANY THANK
YOU. HOW TO THIS CENTER FIELD
OFFICE REPLACE I FIRST I HAVE
THIS. REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE DE
WITH PATIENT CO OR LEAST AND I
DON'T REMEMBER SIR FRANCISCO BE
ON. IN MY RATE. AS THREE CAR TO
THE OTHER DAY ALL. THE ARE NOT
LOCATED IN CITY SAN FRANCISCO
THAT NEED RE. IS THAT THERE WAS
AT MY. I'M READY CUTS THE A
FINDING. SO. IN LAST YEAR'S
RIPPLES OLDER KNOWN TO. IT WAS
TRYING TO DO WHAT WE CAN
THROUGH THROUGH LEAST FIVE ON
THIS H. P.'S OUR PUBLIC
POLITICIANS FUND SIDE AND THE
AND THE JUST TRY TO GET AS MANY
OF THE EGGS FOR. MOVING AS
PH<c.cyan> MOVIE FOR MOVING TO</c>
CONTINUE TO MOVE FOR. SO THIS.
REALIZE THAT WITH YOU KNOW
CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED THAT THERE
ARE SERIOUS DEFICIENCY WITHIN
THE SYSTEM WE LOOKED AT THE-
DEPARTMENTS HIGHEST PRIORITY IN
OUR INCLUDING A NEW PROJECT AND
IN THIS CASE EFFORTS A SIXTY
YEAR OLD. LA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I AM SO WE ONLY REYES
ISSUE WITH THAT THE SAN
FRANCISCO FIELD OFFICE CAP ROLE
OUTLAY PROPOSAL WHICH AS- THE
PART OF FINANCE MENTION
MENTIONED THAT'S THE NEW
PROJECT THIS YEAR- SAID THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSED SAYING
THE OFFICE TO BE BUILT- TO MEET
THIS YEAR AND THE ENERGY
REQUIREMENTS AND I. WE
RECOMMEND THE DEPARTMENT TO
SHOW COST BENEFIT OUR COST
EFFECTIVENESS ANALYSIS OF-
HAVING EASIER IN THE ENERGY
FEATURES- TO THE PROJECT WE
DEFINITELY RECOGNIZED THAT
ENERGY CONSERVATION IS A WORTHY
GOAL AND THAT IT WOULD HELP-
WITH. THE STATE MEETING I AM
ARE CLIMATE GOALS HOWEVER-
ACOSTA EFFECTIVENESS OF
ASSESSMENT- WITH ALLOW AT THE
LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT INCLUDE
INCLUSION OF THESE FEATURES IS
THE BEST. WAY FOR THE STATE TO
CONSERVE ENERGY I AM AT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS- DONE THESE COST
BENEFITS SUSSMAN'S FOR- OTHER
OTHER DMV OFFICES BY GIVEN
THAT. THE ANY FEATURES ARE KIND
OF DEPEND THAT ONLINE- THE-
LOCATION OF THE OFFICES AND IT
VARIES- FROM BUILDING TO
BUILDING WE RECOMMEND- THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER REQUIRING
THE DEPARTMENT TO SHOW SOME
COST EFFECTIVENESS AT THAT THE
ANY FEATURES AT THE OFFICE.
CENTER STERN. THANK YOU I KNOW
WE'VE HAD AS I TUNED IN
YESTRDAY FOR THE EXENSIVE
HEARINGS AND ALL THE OTHER
CHALLENGES YOU GUYS ARE
TACKLING A DMV RIGHT NOW SO
CREATED DEEP DIVE ON THIS VERY
NARROW SET OF ISSUES BUT I AM
WONDERING JUST EITHER FROM LA-
ORDERED DEPARTMENT FINANCE RE
DMV'S PERSPECTIVE. IS THE
PRIORITIZATION PROCESS WHAT WAS
IT- AGE THAT SORT OF DROVE THE-
DECISION MAKING- AT YEAH I AM
JUST SORT OF SEEN A GRAB BAG OF
THINGS HERE BUT I'M SURE
THERE'S A LOGIC BY ANY CAN YOU
GUYS LAY OUT SORT OF HOW YOU.
HOW YOU DID YOUR RANKING. AND
WHAT TYPE OF A FIRE WHICH
REFLECT THE CARE. ARM SO AT
YEAR. EVERY YEAR THE- OF. A
FIVE YEAR INTEREST PLAN WHICH-
LAYS OUT THERE FOR. AND THEN
FROM THAT BASED ON OTHER- BASED
ON FINANCES REVIEW. OUR BASED
ON IN THIS CASE ON CONSTRAINTS
WITHIN THE MTA THEY'LL BE A
LIST AS POSTED ON THE FINANCE
WEBSITES. OF THE APPROVED FIVE
YEAR PLAN- USUALLY FOR DMV THE
THREE MAJOR DRIVERS IS GOING TO
BE. THE WORKLOAD- AT EACH
OFFICE THE AGE OF THE FACILITY
AND THEN ANY IDENTIFIED FIRE
LIFE SAFETY OR SEISMIC
DEFICIENCIES. AND I'M I'M
NOTICING NINE IN THE LOS.
REGION A TO BE BIASED BUT I'M
SURE THERE'S SAN DIEGO I MEAN I
AT THOSE. OLD ENOUGH TO. IS THE
WORKLOAD NOT AS HIGH I'M JUST
CURIOUS HAVE. YET I MEAN
THERE'S OXNARD AYE AYE AYE KNOW
I'M JUST. HOW DOES IT SHAKE OUT
THE ONES. ON THE LIST HERE THEN
I REALIZED THAT MY STRANGE JUST
MY CELL BUT AT RANDI KAYE A
PART IN A FINANCE THERE IS AN
IN PRY. HOWEVER AND NOT A SWING
SPACE FOR. SENSE WITH. SECURING
THE SWINGS ON IT IS FINISHED
WITH DESIGN WAY FOR SWINGS. IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THE FUNCTION. AND BUT WRECK.
THAT THAT WOULD A YEAR. THERE'S
THE CONSTRUCTION FOR IS BEING.
BUT IT I MEAN JUST. FOR BROADER
STRATEGIC THINKING HOW THE
CONSUMER IN IS GONNA WORK
FORWARD AND ALL. BIG TICKET
THINKING I MEAN HOW DOES THIS
SORT OF. CAPITAL PRICE FIT IN
THAT DO YOU DO. SORT OF A- ED
AT THE STRATEGY THE FUTURE KNOW
WHAT WHAT THE RE. ARE TO CAN
FACING SIDE LOOK LIKE A HOW HOW
TO IS SORT OF FITTED WITH THAT
IN. YOUR FIVE YEAR STRUCTURE. I
AM TO I'M CURIOUS TO. DILLON
SAID. THE NEW LOOK AT THE NEW
DMV. SO ABSOLUTELY FOR CA IN.
QUESTION AS WE ALSO TALK ABOUT
MY- THE DMV AND SO WE ARE
ACTUALLY ENGAGED NOW IN A STUDY
WITH THE OFFICE OF THE DMV LOOK
LIKE THAT IS IN CONTROL WITH
OUR PARTNERS AT TGS ON THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCES CERTAINLY
ON PAR THAT CONGRESS. WE'VE
ALSO ENGAGE THE GOV OPSAHL
DEPUTY SECRETARY OVER TGS IN
THAT CONVERSATION- AND SO. WHAT
ENDINGS WERE TALKING ABOUT
WE'VE JUST HAD RECENT
CONVERSATIONS AGAIN WITHTHE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WE
THINK ABOUT MODERNIZING THE DMV
AND WE ARE DRIVING PEOPLE TO
MORE DIGITAL TRANSACTIONS. WHAT
IS THE DEMAND ON OUR FIELD
OFFICE- I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO GET THROUGH
WHAT I CALL THE INITIAL STAGES
OF REAL ID AND THE DEMAND IS
OBVIOUSLY VERY HIGH WITHOUT- SO
AS WE THINK ABOUT BOTH OUR
LEASE SPACE AND OUR OWN SPACE
WHAT IS THAT FOR PRINT ME TO
LOOK LIKE. IS THERE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO
ACTUALLY PARTNER WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND HOW WE USE OUR
SPACE THESE ARE ALL THINGS WITH
LOVE TO LOOK AT- YOU KNOW WE
ALL HAVE KIND OF OUR VISION OF
THE DMV OFFICE OF THE FUTURE
PROBABLY LOOKING LIKE SOMETHING
YOU SEE IN COMMERCIALS AROUND
WHAT MODERN BANKS LOOK LIKE-
THAT WOULD BE REALLY FUN AND
EXCITING- AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD WE'RE GONNA GET A
PRESENTATION FROM THE VENDOR
THAT WE BROUGHT IN TO DO THE
STUDY FOREST'S WE'LL BE GETTING
THAT PRESENTATION SOON. AND
US TO START INCORPORATING INTO
OUR FIELD OFFICES WHETHER IT'S
WE STAYED AT LEAST BASED ON
WHAT IS THAT WE SPACE COULD
REQUIRE FROM TEN IMPROVEMENTS-
FOR OUR OWN SPACE INTO WE HANG
ON TO THAT SPACE. TO LOOK AT
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND HOW DO
WE USE THAT SPACE GOING FORWARD
SO CENTER STERN ABSOLUTELY FAIR
QUESTION WE ARE CONTEMPLATING
ALL OF THAT AND DO YOU DO HAVE
FROM THIS FRAMEWORK IS THIS
AFFORD YOU SOME FLEXIBILITY
BASED ON THE LEASE ARRANGEMENTS
THAT YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT JUST
TO STAY NIMBLE WITH THAT I MEAN
IS THAT. I KNOW THE STRUCTURE
OF SOME OF THESE FUNDS IT IS. A
LITTLE BIT IT'S NOT. THERE
OUTLAY PRIOR. BUT THE NAY THE
CON. IS THAT ALLOW YOU MORE
FLIGHT. I CAN WHAT I LOVE OUR
FIVE YEAR INSTEAD IN FIRST PLAN
IS IT'S A MESS TO PRO. SO WE
TAKE IT IN STEPS IN PHASES SO I
WOULD SAY YES IT ALLOWS US TO
CONTEMPLATE THINGS AND IF WE
HAVE TO COURSE CORRECT IT
ALLOWS US TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
COURSE CORRECTION BEFORE WERE
LIKE. KNEE DEEP INTO DOING
CONSTRUCTION WORK AND SO THAT
IS YOU KNOW WITH A FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN WITH KIND
OF A ONE YEAR LOOK WE'RE ABLE
TO DO THOSE THOUGHTFUL WHAT I
CALL BUSINESS PLANNING
ACTIVITIES THANK YOU FOR THAT
INSIGHT. HELP BOB LET'S OPEN UP
TO. HEARING THIS IS A NUMBER
FOURTEEN. DMV'S CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS. CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
AND LET'S MOVE TARA LAST ITEM.
ASIDE TODAY THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER FIFTEEN THE MOTOR VOTER-
RESOURCES PLEASE OKAY SO THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING AN
AUGMENTATION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND OF THIRTY EIGHT ADDITIONAL
ONGOING POSITIONS AND SIX POINT
FOUR MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO F. FOUR POINT ONE
THREE AND ONGOING FOR CONTINUED
ADMINISTRATION OF THE MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM. ONE TIME FUNDING
OF NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND IS
REQUESTING IS WERE BEING
REQUESTED IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FOR CONTINUED
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY BETTER
SUPPORT AND TRANSFER KNOWLEDGE.
THE DMV HAS ADDRESSED THE NY
ASSESSMENT RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
AUGUST OF TWENTY NINETEEN
DEPARTMENT HAS ALSO MAINTAINED
A QUALITY ASSURANCE PROCESS TO
ENSURE THE TIMELY RELEASE OF
RECORDS TO SECRETARY OF STATE.
DMV AS A SHIRT LEGAL AND
COMPLIANCE RESOURCES THAT ARE
ASSIGNED TO THE PROGRAM AND
ESTABLISH DATA GOVERNANCE
POLICIES. INCLUDING DATA
RETENTION AND DATA SHARING.
DEPARTMENT HAS IMPLEMENTED
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM WORK FLOW
INCLUDING THE LIMITATION OF
CHANGE OF ADDRESS GETTING TIME
AS WELL AS STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS OF THE D. L. I. D.
RIDDLES. THE DMV AND SECRETARY
OF STATE HOW FORMED OVER GROUP
TO ADDRESS ONGOING VOTER.
RECORD COLLECTION PROCESSING
AND DELIVERING ACTIVITIES. THE
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN MOTOR VOTER BCP OF
TWELVE POSITIONS AND THREE
POINT ONE BILLION IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO ADMINISTER AND
PROCESS THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH THE MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM. A
BUDGET AUGMENTATION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND IS NEEDED TO
COMPLETE THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN
MAINTAINED ADMINISTRATION OF
THE MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM WITHOUT
CONTINUING TO A DIVERSE
ADVERSELY AFFECT APARTMENTS
REGISTRATION AND LICENSING
OPERATIONAL WORKLOADS. THIS
PROPOSAL WILL ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH MEETING THE MANDATE FIVE
INTENDED REQUIREMENTS. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
JUST BECAUSE OUR EFFORTS AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. NET YOU HAVE WE THE
TEMP. MOVE FIFTY PEOPLE OVER
EVE. INCORPORATE SOME CHIU SOME
OF. SO YOU HAVE SO WE RETURN AS
HE TO THERE THEIR SPOT THIRTY
EIGHT PLUS TWELVE REMAINS THIS
THE SAME. THE QUESTION LIKE AS
THESE QUESTION IS THIS PERSON
WHO'S THERE ONLY DOING MOTOR
VOTER- WORK. I MEAN THESE
PEOPLE. I'M TRUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT I COME IN AND I
CHANGE MY ADDRESS IS IN THAT I
THOUGHT IT WAS JUST AN
AUTOMATIC THAT WOULD GO TO THE-
SECRETARY OF STATE OR TO THE
COUNTY REGISTER VOTER TO DO IT.
WHAT IS THE ADDITIONAL WORK
THAT THAT THIS ORDER VOTER
PERSON WOULD BE DOING A CHANGE
OF ADDRESS FOR SUGGEST A
REGULAR DMV EMPLOYEE DOING A
CHANGE OF ADDRESS. OKAY SIR
OKAY SUCK SO AT. THEY CAN OF
GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF HOW KIND OF
WORKS IF THE DONE. I'M OFFICE
THIS IS THE OF GET UP. AT ME.
BUT WHEN SOMEONE FILLS OUT OF
ADDRESS FORM AND LET'S SAY THAT
THEY OR THEY- UPDATE THEIR-
ADDRESS OTHER DRIVERS LICENSE
ID RENEWAL. AS IT COMES IN AT
THE MOMENT IT WAS COMING IN.
AND WE WOULD HAVE TO UPDATE IT
INTO OUR CAN THE MOTOR VOTER IN
TWO. THE DIEM SYSTEM ADD TO THE
THAT GOES SECTOR OF STATE. SO
THERE WAS ALL OF WORK WE US BUT
THAT WE DON'T HAVE. IS THE AT
THE TIME TO. AND PUTTING IT IN
TO BOTH. WERE BARRING POSITIONS
FOR ELSEWHERE. NOW THAT WE
SECURE THE KERR FUNDING. FOR
THIS YEAR. IT WAS. PROPOSED FOR
NECK YEAR I DOUBT WE HAVE. RISK
TO. THAT WERE LOAD UP WITH IN.
BUT IS THAT MA'AM I'M CHAU MY
IGNORANCE. IS THE AND- TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. THAT'S
COMPUTER WORK MEAN I GET THE I.
THE WORK THAT YOU GOT TO GIVE
THE NEW WHITE. AND PRINT DATA
IT IS AND- OKAY HERE COME I'M
HERE. PROCESSING RIDGE. AND OR
WHATEVER IT IS. COMES IN I
CHANGED INTO. I'M ISSUING THE
CAR IN ECHO. BECAUSE OVER TO.
THE REGISTER THEY SAID. STATE
OR IS THAT TOO SO. OF AN UNDER.
OR IN THIS. I GUESS I'M NOT
APPRECIATE. APPRECIATING THE
ADDITIONAL WORK. WHEN PEOPLE
COME IN IN THE- COURSE OF. I
NEED TO DO. TO GET MY DRIVE
LICENSE AND I'M UP TO STEPPED.
WE ALL KNOW THAT A LOT OF.
THEIR WEIGHT INCLUDED AS THAT
AN UPDATE WITH THE D. RIGHT AT
THAT IN. SO IS. WELL HERE'S
YOUR HERE BE FOR FIFTY
POSITIONS AT 38% RIGHT SO.
ALEJO WHAT DO YOU HAVE SAY SO
REGARD THIS PROPOSAL I AM SAD
THAT HAD ANNOUNCES WE AT
RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ASK FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
OUTCOMES OF THAT PROCESS
EFFICIENCIES AS WELL AS- HOW
WELL THE IDEA BE WAS ABLE TO
MEET THE FIVE DAY TURNAROUND-
NEAR THE VOTER REGISTRATION
DEADLINE FOR THE MARCH
ELECTION- SINCE THEN THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
SHOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
MEET THAT FIVE DAY- DEADLINES
WITH THE RESOURCES. BUT WE
STILL RECOMMEND I'M ASKING
DEPARTMENT FOR- EDITION
INFORMATION ON THE OUTCOMES OF
THE PROCESS EFFICIENCIES AS
THAT BECOMES FULLY IMPLEMENTED.
SENATOR STIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- CAN YOU ELABORATE JUST
ON THE E. Y. REPORT LITTLE BIT
MAYBE SPEAK TO SOME OF THOSE
PROCESS EFFICIENCIES JUST HELP
US UNDERSTAND. THE IS THIS A
VERY I. T. CENTRIC THE THIRTY
EIGHT HERO A- UP THE CHAIR AND
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE DAY
TODAY AND- YEAH THIS IS FOR THE
NEW STREAMLINED PROCESS THAT HE
Y. OUTLINE. KATHY WEBB CHIEF TO
BE DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT MOTOR
VEHICLES SO- IF YOU GO BACK TO
THE E. Y. ASSESSMENTS THERE ARE
SEVERAL THINGS THAT WERE
ADDRESSED IN IN PRINCIPALLY AT
A HIGH LEVEL GOVERNANCE AND HOW
WE WERE WORKING WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE- OUR OWN
INTERNAL PROCESS SEES. AND I
THINK WHAT LEE WAS ACTUALLY
ALLUDING TO AS WELL THERE IS
THE ONLINE PROCESS AND
OBVIOUSLY THAT OFFER SOME
EFFICIENCY BUT WE ALSO PROVIDE
A CHECKS AND BALANCES BEFORE
WHICH JUST SEND SOMETHING OVER.
WHICH WE CALL KIND OF OUR OUR
VOTER EXAMINATION TO MAKE SURE
THINGS ARE ARE MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS THE SIGNATURE
MATCHES ALL THOSE THINGS THAT
GO ON. UNFORTUNATELY WHAT HAS
BEEN MORE DIFFICULT FOR US IS
THE PAPER PROCESS AND WE STILL
HAVE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
RELY ON THE PAPER PROCESS AND
WHILE WE HAVE SCANNING SYSTEMS
WHICH YOU AFFORDED TO US- NOT
ALL SCANNING SYSTEMS PICKUP
WRITING THAT IS A LOGICAL OR
INFORMATION NOT COMPLETED AND
FORTY WHEN YOU HAVE. THE PAPER
PROCESS YOU HAVE A CHANCE FOR
WHAT I CALL MORE ERRORS THAT
HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED SO IT
REALLY IS CREATED INCREDIBLE
WORKLOAD FOR US AND- AND WHILE
I WOULD TELL YOU IT'S A SMALL
FRACTION OF WHAT COMES THROUGH
IN OUR PROCESSING IT DRIVES
MOST OF THE MANUAL WORK. THAT
WE HAVE TO DO SO- THE POSITIONS
THAT WE ARE REQUESTING AS WE
HAVE A WHOLE SEPARATE MOTOR
VOTER SYSTEM AND SO IT'S THE I.
T. KINDA MANAGEMENT IS LOOKING
AT CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN IT WILL
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE OUR IT
SYSTEMS PROVIDE THE MONITORING
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE IN IT- AND
THEN THERE'S THE PROCESSING AND
OUR REMITTANCE SECTION THAT
STILL. IS TAKING IN THIS PAPER
VOLUME- AND IN AGAIN WE DON'T
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY BUT WE
TRY TO ENSURE THE QUALITY OF
THE DOCUMENTS WERE SENDING OVER
TO SECRETARY STATE SO THEY CAN
THEM PROCESS THOSE DOCUMENTS.
AND SENATOR I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT DOES IT WOULD YOU HAVE THE
FEDERAL APARTMENTS FOR TEN AND
FIVE DAYS SO WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE A CHANCE TO GO BEYOND
THOSE TIME WISE WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE TWO WRITERS
ACTORS SO WHAT YOU'RE
DELIVERING OVER TO SECRETARY.
STATE HAS GOT TO BE. TYPE AND
AS C<c.cyan>. AS POSSIBLE.THE</c>
AROUND THEN THAT AND IT. IN
TIGHT SO. THE TEXT AND WE DID
WE DID DO A QUICK LOOK BACK AS
WE KIND OF. ALLEY SCUTTLED STAY.
INFECTED DURING THE PRIMARY. TO
ENSURE THAT HOW MUCH PERCENTAGE
OF OUR RECORDS ARE ACTUALLY
GOING OVER THERE. ABOUT 99%
THOSE RECORDS HAVE GONE OVER
AND THE ONLY REASON WHY MAY NOT
BE A HOW 2% AS AN EXAMPLE. IS
THAT WE DO HAVE SOME BUSINESS
PROCESSES IN PLACE SAY SOMEONE
IS TRYING AS IS DECEASED AND
THEIR INFORMATION IS TRYING TO
COME THROUGH OUR- SYSTEM FOR
KICK THAT OUT. AS IF THE STATE
ARE AYE HERE'S- AB. THE NEED
PURSUE. BUT IT'S FAIR TO SAY
THOUGH THAT EVEN THOUGH
SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD DEMAND-
ACTUALLY DO MORE WORK WITH
FEWER PEOPLE GOING FORWARD FROM
THESE PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS THAT
A FAIR ASSESSMENT OF HOW YOU'VE
OUTLINED THE BUDGET HERE RIGHT
AND SO WE'RE GONNA AVE
ENHANCED MONITORING WHICH WILL
BE IN PLACE ALL YET HAVE MORE
OF LIKE A REAL TIME LOOK AT.
THE LOOK OF FIX THE IT FIXING
ISSUES IN REAL TIME OTHER KIND
OF FLOWING FOR SYSTEMS TO
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE RECORDS
TO GO OVER POTS WILL HAVE LIKE
A DATA REPORTING TOOL BUT I CAN
KIND OF TRACK THE LIFE OF THE
RECORDS. JUST MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE AS EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE
YOU AND WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNER SECTORS STATE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY LET'S OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC HEARING THIS IS-
PARTNER MOTOR VEHICLE. ISSUE
NUMBER FIFTEEN MOTOR VOTER
RESOURCES. CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
RENO- COMMENT I UNDERSTAND THAT
A THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
VEHICLES AND A STANDARD-
SENATOR REQUIRES EN ROUTE. OKAY
WHY DON'T WE CALL THE ROLL TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM DMV THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT
CASTING HERE DOLLY REQUIRE
MONNING STAR. THANK CENTER. I
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF FROM A
FEW MINUTES TO SEE IF WE CAN
ESTABLISH FORM. THE TRADITION.
L. YEAH. SOYEAH I THINK. YEAH
THAT'S ANOTHER THING THAT. LIKE
IF YOU WERE A PROVIDER. JUMP IN
BUT- AND.
I BACK ON THE RECORD
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM
WATER. ALL RIGHT OF WE YOU HAVE
AS A QUORUM WE ARE NOW
ADJOURNED.
TO THE MORE. NEXT
ISSUE ALL RIGHT MOVING WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO START ON THIS
ISSUE FOR RIGHT ISSUE FOUR
DOZEN NINE NINE ROSE OR BUT
THAT'S RIGHT- SO WE'RE MOVING
ON TO ENROLLMENT A UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S REQUESTING-
THIRTY FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ENROLLMENT OF WHICH
THIRTEEN MILLION